cold he got because he stayed out and
gave such a long speech so
for the health of the republic and the
president probably ought to give a short
speech
president clinton on the next book notes
now international brotherhood of
teamsters president ron kerry
as a federal overseer continued to tally
the final ballots mr kerry held a news
conference saturday to declare victory
in this week's teamster president
election
mr carrie was opposed by james p hoffa
the son of former labor leader jimmy
hoffa in his bid for a second five-year
term
the union reports having 1.4 million
members
this news conference lasts about 30
minutes
[Applause]
country
hello
hello
this is mr kerry
yes we will be taking the questions in a
few moments
no
i'll do the presentation then we'll take
okay thanks so much
will you be giving me a signal at the
time that you want to answer questions
[Music]
thank you
ladies and gentlemen thank you for
standing by
and welcome to the ron carey
teleconference at this time all
participants are in the living room mode
later we will conduct a question and
answer session instructions will be
given at that time if you should require
assistance during the call please to
press star followed by xero i would now
like to turn the conference over to our
host mr ron kerry please go ahead
thank you
i'm proud to say that our reform slate
has won
we have a solid lead
and there is nothing
about the remaining locals or the
challenge ballots
that would in any way change the outcome
of this election
if you have any technical questions
about the challenge ballots
the current count
or any other aspect of the process
my campaign staff will be here to answer
your questions
when i am finished talking with you
i want to talk to you today
not about the technical issues
but about what this result really means
this is not a victory
for one
or
man
a slate of candidates
it's a victory for all working people
who want strong honest unions
this is a victory for the continued
reform
the continued changes that are necessary
within the teamster union
let me say it as it is
we beat the mob
we beat corporate america
we beat the old guard officials in our
union
it's a victory for those thousands of
members
who work night and day
to make sure that teamster reform
continues
they are the real heroes
of this election
this victory sends a message to every
gree employer
who is trying to cut and destroy good
jobs
good full-time jobs with decent benefits
and i'm going to tell you now
as i said in 1999
1991
we are not going to
let those
destroy the great american dream
this victory also sends a message
to every mob boss in america
our treasury
our pension funds
will never
ever again be used for organized crime
in a form of a piggy bank
this victory
sends a message to every teamster
official
who has tried to undermine reform in the
past five
years it's time for them
to get on
the reform train
or get the hell out of the way
i'm proud
not only that we came out ahead
but i'm proud that we won on the issues
even before the vote was counted
because of our reforms of the past five
years
we forced the officials supporting
junior
to adopt our platform
just
two short years ago
they oppose striking to stop the freight
companies from shifting good full-time
jobs
to low-wage part-time positions
they refuse to support our one-day
strike to demand safe handling
of heavier packages at ups
they stood outside this building
to protest
the elimination
of the area conferences bureaucracies
which paid outrageous multiple salaries
outrageous multiple pensions
and all sorts of other perks for union
officials
they tried in court
to stop me
from
letting the members vote on the future
of teams to finances and services
at our 1991 convention
junior's back is opposed the right of
teamster members to elect
top officials and convention delegates
they have said and so has many of the
pension plans
that the 25 year and out pension
programs that we have worked for
were out of the question
they were indeed pie in the sky
but guess what
in 1996
you would have thought that junior in
his back is
invented all of these reform issues
juniors
come lately conversion to reform was not
real
but the fact that he had to copy our
platform
showed how far we have moved the debate
in this union
our victory
is remarkable
a remarkable upset
when you consider the advantages that
junior had
his slate
raised almost
four million dollars
and that's at the end of november
more than
twice the 1.6 million dollars that we
raised
they had the support of many local union
officials
and yes
many local
employers
and national employers
they were assured of news coverage
because of junior's famous name
but they didn't have the vision
to make this union strong
we've raised many members expectations
and we've encouraged them to speak out
and i will continue to urge members
to know their rights to get more
involved in this union
at every level
it's time to put the election behind us
unite this union keep building a strong
honest union
and i want to say to every teamster
member
every local union official who is ready
to support
reform no matter how you mark your
ballot
you are the important part
of the teamster team
and i welcome your suggestions your
cooperation
your hard work to build this union
in the years ahead
now i'd like to say something
personal to the news media
and it's not necessarily for the cameras
but just so that you know
on monday morning i will be going in
to have knee surgery
it's something i've needed
for the past
two years
it's a result of an old sports injury
it will be an inconvenience to me
as it will be to you in terms of trying
to get access
but the doctors tell me that within
a couple of weeks i should be in
terrific shape with that knee
and fully recovered
so now if you have any questions about
the meaning of the election
i'll be happy to answer them and after
that if you have questions about the
technical aspect the election process
the campaign staff is here to answer
that as well
yes your first five years
no corruption
no exceptions
no excuses
we're going to continue to do what we've
done
to root out corruption in this union and
put this union back in the hands of the
membership
and we will continue that organizing
yes sir
you talked about the importance of
unifying reunifying the union you've had
some harsh words today from mr harper
and his supporters how will you go about
reunifying the union
i have always taken the position
that this union belongs to everyone
i have always taken the position that
the reforms that have taken place in
this union like cleaning it up like
putting the emphasis on organizing
standing up to employers
vitally important i'm hopeful
that
they will look at what's happened in
1991
and look at what's happened today
considering all
of the obstacles that we had to face the
money the employer's help
uh all of those items which certainly
didn't benefit our campaign they've lost
twice
and so i think that sends a very large
signal out there
i
i think
one of the major obstacles that working
people have today is the fact that
they see their wages
moving back what i think standing up to
employers is an extremely important
issue that we have to deal with
getting the members involved more in
that in that process
not just having the union officials do
it but this is a fight for all working
people in this country building a strong
labor movement and trying to bring the
pieces together i will always work
trying to bring people together to work
for the common good however it certainly
won't compromise my position on issues
like standing up to employers corruption
looking the other way for 88 years this
union
has had major problems with people
looking the other way with condoning
things that are wrong
and so it has been a difficult five
years
and i think the messages out there some
of the tough tough positions that we had
to take
is out there we're going to continue
those fights on things that are
important for our members
well i don't think mr harper stood for
reform in fact i don't think he could
collect
or develop a program
or a strategy until he saw some of the
things that we were doing and then i
think the members took a look at that
and said he's not for real
and as a result they have spoken
have you reviewed the results from the
master freight vocals and if you have to
they appear to validate
the contract that you brought in
at this right time
well i think the validation was there
when they voted on it over 80 percent
i don't have the specific breakdown for
the freight people the ups people and
things of that nature but i think we've
carried our own in those areas
even with all of the smut
and all of the stuff that he tried to
stir up fact of the matter is people are
smart today they understand the problems
but they want to see a union that's out
there that'll be fighting for them
and that is what this union is about
fighting for the future
absolutely i will go through every
statistic there and try to analyze it uh
but i think we've done okay in many of
those areas
yes
sir the
they're gonna elections
and cast doubt upon whether you even won
well i think
it's sour grapes it's another smoke
screen it's something that he's done
straight through
everything that we've tried to do he's
tried to distort it fact of the matter
is the membership has spoken
and i think what he ought to do
is to go back to his law practice and do
the best thing for this membership
some of your support your opponent
supporters believed or were led to
believe that he would be able to
negotiate
large raises like teamsters used to get
in the trucking industry was regulated
uh are you going to what message do you
have for them are the times different
now is it not possible to get
uh big raises like it used to be
possible to get or what would be planned
we will continue to do the very best we
can sure there are change in times and i
think what he relied upon was talking
about the boom times uh that doesn't
exist anymore today we're dealing with
with global con companies conglomerates
a whole different
uh structure however the most important
thing is you have to look at the bottom
line in terms of corporate profits in in
terms of corporate responsibility in
terms of how corporate corporations
today are no longer concerned about
workers that means we have to be the
fighting force for our members and we're
going to continue that fight
and and fight harder and harder for
their future because that's what this
union is all about
them
yes the convention this summer in
philadelphia you had a
call for a special convention after the
elections will you still call for that
we are looking at all of that
uh
we haven't put any plans together
because obviously this was the
focus of our attention uh we will look
at that and and
and come up with some decisions down the
road yes ron i spoke with a observer
this morning who said that you won
because people wanted reform but it was
so close
because people the idea of a more
powerful more effective union did have
appealed you know the the harking back
to when the teamsters were i think as
well as over close to four million
dollars had a tremendous appeal the fact
that they could spend four million
dollars the fact that they had employers
that were out there stuff and pay
envelopes with literature the fact that
they had employers putting material up
all of these things obviously had an
effect but this was not about
individuals
i mean just look at what has happened
this was about
the things that are important for
working people our platform
the things that we've put into place
and so you could look at numbers but i
think what you have to look at when they
shifted
their
position and said we're all reformers
we're all reformers now
uh we're talking about fighting for the
members where have they been
and so just to get them to shift their
position their message
is a major victory for the membership
and that's what it's really all about
let me just i'm sorry
we have the specifics and our folks
would be delighted to give you some
answers on that we also have some
information which i was not about to
bring out and probably have some
problems with my own people
where they had some of their
some employers had some of their major
lobbyists
who work for them
uh
doing work
in some
way or form
in support of the hafa team and one of
them is united parcel service
do you have any intentions to sit down
with mr hoffa and seek to get him to
line up behind you and get his many
supporters to fully back you i'll go
back to that train we're moving out of
the station
the station is about reform the station
and the train is about moving this union
forward cleaning up the corruption
now certainly if he wants to get on that
train and be supportive and stop moving
in that direction many of his supporters
and i suspect many of them will
then we encourage that and welcome it
but
if that is not the intention then
the train's moving out of the station
and goodbye god bless you
[Applause]
is there an intention in the second term
to get more involved from the
international level
tradition of legalization yes
and um
most of the
and i guess at this point it's no longer
campaign rhetoric was about how we were
trying to centralize the union our whole
thrust has always been for the
international union to be the arm
that would reach out and provide the
kinds of things that the local unions
needed whether it was a corporate
campaign whether it was organize
organizing education research that's
what we've done
and of course that has created in the
eyes of those who like to twist things
around
uh that it was the international trying
to get involved in the local union's
business
our whole purpose today tomorrow and in
the future
will be
providing the strength the resources the
kinds of things that the local unions
need
to move forward and to take on the tough
fights
mr kerry we have some
questions on the phone i wonder if we
might want to take those sure just tell
them
okay
do you have any questions
hello congratulations
thank you this is ken dermato from the
nbc radio network and i'd like to know
um
further down the road five years from
now
are you going to be able to during the
period of your next term be able to
consolidate your
ideas and consolidate yourself so that
these reforms don't get flung backwards
and so you don't have a successful
challenger five years from now
uh absolutely we will continue doing the
i think what you have to keep in mind
ken
is that when you look back over the
history of this union 88 years of
neglect 88 years of sweeping things
under the carpet we will continue to
work to put into place those procedures
those kinds of reforms
that will be very difficult to untangle
and to dismantle so we're going to
continue to work in that direction ken
and is the reform movement within your
union going to play an increasing role i
think the reform
movement in this union has spoken today
that what this was all about was about
them they wanted a strong honest union
and they were the ones who made this
possible today
next question on the phone
we now have a question from john lippert
of bridge news please go ahead
hello mr kerry hi john
hey can you tell us
what the next step is in detroit
john i would not want to do that i'd be
revealing
some confidential uh
moves that we may have and do have
so uh
obviously it's
it's the primary objective
to try to get that problem resolved and
i will be speaking with you in the
future
thank you
we now have a question from harry
bernstein of the la times please go
ahead
a man who has helped several of your
predecessors in public relations
is now
just written a book do you plan to try
and get him
uh duke zeller to work with you at your
organization
harry you always give those tough tough
questions
which
yeah uh well by the way i think some of
the statements he made are nothing but a
lie
uh
and a total distortion of the facts the
answer to that question is where the
duke is at right now that's the best
place for him to be
[Applause]
next question on the phone we now have a
question from dan leduc of philadelphia
enquirer please go ahead ryan
congratulations uh thanks dan you were
at 48 of those five years ago and you
moved it up to about 52 this year that
still means that this is a pretty
divided union how difficult is your task
yet
you will have some hoffa slate members
on your board and what does it say that
almost half of your union was still
willing to vote for mr hoffman
i think there there are some definite
problems but uh i think if you look at
the numbers we have moved up we've had
to make some very difficult decisions in
this union
uh we will continue to do that and i
will continue to be the members
president
uh i will continue to make the tough
decisions the cuts that are necessary
going out there dealing a body blow to
corruption and as you know through the
years all we've heard about was this is
retaliation retaliation but the bottom
line it's about a clean honest union and
i'm going to continue to do that
i wish i could get out to every bond to
every location and to meet with members
more than i have in the past but that's
a difficult process i'm going to
continue to try to do more to meet the
members so that they get an opportunity
to know more about ron kerry
we now have a question from kenneth pro
of newsday please go ahead
congratulations ron thanks ken why do
you think uh your message did not reach
that 48 percent that voted against you
because uh hoffer obviously went beyond
appealing to just the local barons or
leaders of
unions and reached to a mass of the
membership well i think if you look at
the mass of the membership
a lot of them
as you will
remember uh a majority of the local
union leadership
uh have been supportive of him you saw
that at the convention
and uh we don't we're not able to get
our message into some of those areas
and i just think that the 3.7 million
dollars or close to 4 million had a lot
to do with it uh the fact that the
leadership was out there they connect
with them every single day
so i mean i think some of those are the
reasons and we'll look more
once we get the rest of the statistics
in but i think that we've moved forward
it's uh in my opinion it's a remarkable
upset considering the obstacles that we
had to face a majority of the leadership
in this country was supporting him
majority probably of employers were
supporting him uh close to four million
dollars those are all pretty tough
opponents
all right another part of the question
uh are you going to drop your libel suit
against copper i am not
[Applause]
another question on the phone our next
question comes from ron sharer of
christian science monitor please go
ahead
congratulations ron thank you yeah good
i wanted to ask you one more question
going back to that 48
if there's some message though that
hoffa was with was sending out that you
have to pay attention to is there
something that he said that maybe
resonates with the members that you may
have to have to think about over the
next five years
well i think in
unions today what's happening in this
country the disappointments
this country with the corporate greed
that we have i mean it it's easy to
understand that if you use this word
uh power people sometimes buy into it
but the fact of the matter is in the end
result we will look at every aspect of
of this campaign we will look at all of
the areas of the country and i think at
that time we'll be able to make some
decisions about
some of the things that took place and
and and try to make uh adjustments
we now have a follow-up question from
dan la duke of the philadelphia inquirer
please go ahead ron one other question
about federal oversight and that's um
there is no provision for the next
election five years from now do you
anticipate uh judge edelstein's role uh
diminishing would you think that the
union has proven some things to the
judge that will allow the federal
government to uh to begin to ease up on
its oversight of the of the teamsters i
think you have to take a look at our
track record our position with respect
to corruption
no exceptions no excuses no corruption
we're going to continue to work in that
direction with respect to what judge
edelstein
uh may think what he may do
that's a question you'll have to check
with judge edelstein about
would you would you uh certainly want
that to happen i mean do you think the
union has progressed to the point where
you can make a case to him
that that uh there is a lesser role now
for for the government or certainly by
the end of the next five years there
would be
a lesser role necessary for the
government well i try to make that case
by our actions and the steps that we've
taken every single day i do know this
you do not get rid of corruption you do
not get rid of federal oversight you did
not get rid of the independent review
board
until you're able to show that you have
what it takes
to cleanse this union to keep it clean
in the future the kinds of
programs like the ethical practices
committee
that will not happen until you're able
to prove you're getting the job done i
think this is the beginning clearly not
the end there is a lot more that has to
be done and i will continue to work in
that direction and that's probably why
we had a very tough election because the
major issue
was about corruption if you share the
member
or if you deny a member his rights that
he has worked his ass off for in his
pension programs his health programs
then that's corruption and we're going
to continue to go out there and do the
job for our members that they elected us
to do
[Applause]
any other questions out
yes sir had a slight uh increase in your
membership last year do you have a goal
for how large you'd like this member
this union to be five years from now
well
i guess
yeah i could give you a number but that
may not be realistic but i can tell you
this what's happening in this country is
remarkable the enthusiasm the energy the
fact that working people have been
taking it on the chin they don't see any
way to get a remedy to that except by
belonging to union having a contract in
black and white and we have been doing
terrific and
i think just the other day we want a
couple of other small elections we're
going to continue to do that because
organizing is the lifeline of this union
and we have said so by prioritizing our
resources in the areas
of organizing
our final question from the phone lines
comes from kenneth crowe of newsday
please go ahead
what are you going to do about the
strike fund or the absence of the strike
fund in the teamsters
we will be putting together a
committee next year
to look at all aspects of the strike
fund
there are very large differences and
variables for example i mean just one
which you can connect with ken in the
public service division they can't
really get a lot of uh
of money out of the strike front because
of the taylor law and in different parts
of the country so we have to look at
what's right for the membership that
committee will meet it will be
consist of
of teamsters from every aspect of this
union both supporters and nun supporters
uh what this is about it's about
the membership it is not about politics
and hopefully we can put that behind us
let's get the politics behind us and
let's get this union working for the
membership another part of the question
another question
do you think uh that this election could
have been carried off honestly without
the court supervision and close watching
of the results
i don't think so in fact it was my
understanding that just yesterday
some of my opponents
there was some facts that came out
yesterday were carrying ballots in and
out of a particular teamster
building and so i don't think so
hopefully over the next five years we'll
be able to develop rules and regulations
that would provide for
this kind of will will stop this kind of
practice from happening as a result of
that
are you willing to have the teamsters
pay for supervision in the next election
by an outside uh force such as the
powers personally ken i don't want the
teams to pay for anything
but the fact of the matter is uh
democracy has a
it's a high price tag
and it cost a lot of money for democracy
and we'll take a look at that once we
get all the facts in and make some
decisions about that
and so with that uh i'd like to thank
you all so much
thank you
[Applause]
five four six
[Applause]
[Applause]
he's better yeah
james hoffa son of former teamsters
president jimmy hoffa is challenging mr
kerry's claim of victory
following mr carey's news conference mr
hoffa held his own to talk about his
vision for the future of that labor
organization
[Applause]
it appears that we have come to the
final stage
of this election process
uh we are presently uh at a position
where the numbers do not look good uh
this is not a concession speech there
are a number of challenge ballots that
must must be counted
but i think the overall view is
that uh when the ballots will count are
counted uh that it does appear that uh
it's going to be a very very close race
extremely close and it's not a time for
a concession speech but it is one that
it does look like it is possible that
ron kerry will be re-elected
so what we have to talk about is where
do we go from here and i think the
issues are where does this union go from
here uh and throughout this campaign we
have talked about this union that is on
the edge of bankruptcy that is uh
negotiating concessionary contracts in
the trucking industry united parcel
service that people are being hurt by
the ron kerry leadership that we have a
union that went 15 months without a
strike fund that we have a union that
presently uh
has only a 55-hour strike fund which is
completely inadequate for its members
and finally we have a union that is
completely divided and the vote in this
election shows that if you take canada
out that this union is divided 50-50
that i received uh in this vote to the
same amount of votes that ron kerry did
if you take the united states of america
you take canada out so what is that
message to ron kerry and is he listening
is there anybody out there i think the
answer is
can we really stand five more years of
what he has been doing
or is ron kerry
going to listen to the members
listen
just a minute listen to the messages
that are going for the members when half
of the members in this union are saying
we're on the wrong course that we are on
a course that is leading to our
destruction that we don't want bad
contracts that we don't want a divided
union we want unity is ron kerry going
to listen to the membership or is he
going to contain and continue on the
road where this union remains two
divided groups of people you know
abraham lincoln said that a house
divided against itself cannot stand
this union today is a house divided and
this vote underlines that very fact that
something has to be done to pull this
union together
and i want to say at this point that i
am more than happy to work with ron
kerry to start to rebuild this union to
start to unify this union because if we
just take the united states vote i got
as many votes as he did
or that is that is the issue what is he
going to do
is he going to react and say it's time
for us to work together it's time to
build a united house it's time to start
working towards better contracts or does
he continue on the same course of
division and lies is he going to
continue out that's the issue that faces
the members there are many positive
things that came out of this campaign
and one of those is the fact that we
have elected we have elected six
international vice presidents these are
hawker vice presidents
[Applause]
and
it is just so great that we were able to
elect five people from
from the central uh phil young
uh pat flynn walt lytle les singer
dottie milinski we were able to elect
chuck mack from the west and with the
voting still going on it's possible that
we could have a seventh and eighth so
these are really good trends because
these hoffa vice presidents have given a
mandate to go
to the executive board to represent that
50 percent that ron kerry didn't give to
say we have a spokesman here and they
are going to be speaking out to try and
unite this union they're going to be
speaking out for the hoffa program of
stronger contracts a more militant union
not a weaker union that ron kerry has
spoken about that is what we've got to
talk about i also wonder what would have
happened if we had the debates everybody
knows that i tried to debate ron kerry
obviously we were the underdogs we were
outspent a hundred to one they had more
people on the payroll working around the
clock to get ron kerry elected more
mailings than we could ever think to
afford
we were outspent but we weren't
outworked but the fact is we were the
underdog in this race and even with that
underdog status we were able to come up
50 50 in the united states which i think
is rather incredible
finally i would like to point out that
the debates it was my vision of this
campaign that we would talk about the
issues that face the membership that it
would not be about smears it would not
be about smearing each other that it
would be about what are the issues
facing the membership what about the
strike fund
what about our disunited union what
about ups where do we go in organizing
those were the issues that i wanted to
debate those are the issues that i spoke
out on and said let's debate in front of
the membership let's get a video camera
and let's video the debate so that we
can talk and talk like anybody else have
a debate just like clinton and dole with
a moderator where we talk about the
important issues that affect our
families each day and that we would have
this on videotape to send out to
thousands and thousands of teamster
members so they could make an
intelligent decision but that never came
to be that ron kerry was afraid to
debate me he was afraid to stand side by
side with me that he had others try and
do his bidding through the media through
other other courses to try and turn it
around
and that is what happened why didn't we
have that debate i think somebody should
ask ron kerry that and why that debate
didn't come true why is it that co that
clinton and dole debated and why is it
that other people in important positions
debate whether they run for congress or
they run for the senate and why is it
that that didn't come come about it
would have been very helpful to talk
about the important issues that face our
membership and that never came to be and
i think that's a great loss it's a great
loss for our membership it's a great
loss for the democracy of our union and
it's a great loss i think uh for all
involved so i basically want to say
thanks again we have had a great run
this has been a great experience i have
met many wonderful wonderful teamsters
from coast to coast it's probably been
the greatest experience of my life and i
think that it's good that we have dreams
and i had a dream that i could help this
union and i don't i don't think we're
ever going to leave that dream let us
all have our dreams and let us be meet
again tomorrow and thank you very much
[Applause]
hey thank you the official vote count
now gives ron kerry nearly 227 000 votes
about 17 000 more than mr hoffa
over 40 000 ballots are in question
a final vote count should take about a
week
i will faithfully execute the office
as we uh take a look at the uh capital
there on this saturday morning just
across the street there is the teamsters
building this building uh actually right
next to the building we are in here at
400 north capitol street on c-span we
show you the teamsters building this
morning because we are joined in our
studio today by
arthur sloan a professor of industrial
relations at the university of delaware
good morning good morning
and also author of this book which is on
our set here hoffa by arthur a sloan we
are focusing today on the life of jimmy
hoffa and
professor sloan
who was jimmy hoffa and what was his
impact on this country
jimmy hoffa was
probably the best known labor leader of
all time
and was president of the teamsters the
biggest most powerful most colorful
union
that not just this country but i think
the world
has ever known uh from
1957 to
officially 1971 but in fact he had
enormous power and really ran the union
for some period before 1957
and in fact called many of the shots
from lewisburg penitentiary
for a while after he went to prison uh
in late 19 march of 1967 until a couple
of years later when he lost that power
how did he get all this power and and
how was he so effective what was it that
he brought
i don't think any labor leader ever has
had more adulation
from the membership than james r hoffa
they loved him members and we're
speaking of
one and a half million with needless to
say many many exceptions who did not
love him
uh
hoffa
had an enormous cheering section from
especially the truck driver segment the
biggest segment in his era
within the teamsters truck drivers and
warehousemen also
above all because he delivered he
delivered the goods really in spades uh
their uh wages in the hoffa period
depending on what part of the country
we're talking about
doubled
uh
troubled and even more than that
uh certainly the bread and butter
gratitude from the membership was the
major single factor in his
success i think because they did revere
him
but it was also due i think to his
accessibility he was an enormously
accessible guy
i was out there all the time with the
members all over the country and all the
time for hartha we're not speaking of uh
40-hour weeks but more like
like a hundred hour weeks and beyond he
hardly slept he worked seven days a week
and uh very often 16 to 20 hour days all
over the place
touring new terminals taking a turn
behind the wheel of new equipment
just uh always there to the extent of
giving out his
washington telephone numbers uh to the
members uh all over the place you got a
problem just call me just pick up the
phone
uh he also had other qualities i think
that that the pr people with other
teamsters publicized and quite rightly i
think he was a devoted family man
uh who made up in quality time with his
family what the demands of the job
cost them and in terms of uh quantity
time i had uh
an adoring wife a photogenic wife too
who loved him and indeed uh
insofar as anybody can die of a broken
heart josephine hoffa did so five years
after hoffa vanished
uh two uh
two uh photogenic and uh
and uh i think very appealing children
one of whom now
no longer a child
born in 1941 in fact
james philippa is of course president of
the teamsters these days uh hoffa was
fearless he was intelligent
he had a lot of things going for him i
think he didn't spend money on himself
at all he was power hungry no question
about that but he was not uh uh money
hungry uh in any sense on the negative
side and this certainly uh was a huge
negative to offer uh to his discredit if
you give him an a as a labor leader and
i might add on paul going back to that
no other labor leader that i'm aware of
ever received
huge respect from the employers the
irony there of course is that they had
to finance all of the uh
bread and butter all of the wages and
benefits and conditions
that stood off in such good stead with
the members they were equally in hoffa's
cheering section the trucking industry
employers
he stabilized that
formerly dog-eat-dog highly competitive
uh industry and i was convinced
certainly and many others shared this
conclusion that the trucking company
owners and executives much preferred to
be at jimmy hoffa's mercy because they
found him uh a knowledgeable responsible
hard-driving man of his word an ability
to pay man a guy who knew just how far
he could go and who wouldn't
jeopardize the goose that lay the golden
egg the trucking industry back to the
negatives though uh to his discredit if
he gets an a as a there's a professor
talking with a grading system gets an a
if i could give an a plus he'd get an a
plus within the dimensions of labor
leadership
he would have to get an f
as a citizen a citizen
he uh twice to his discredit
was found guilty
uh of the crimes once jury tampering
trying to bribe three different jurors
indeed uh and uh also of uh in the same
year which was 1964
his appeals were exhausted in 67 and he
went to prison then
also of mail and wire
fraud
he also a pragmatic guy who made his
alliances as he rose to power wherever
he had him
uh
some of his closest friends and allies
were dedicated socialist intellectuals
huff was not very political but
these were the people in charge of uh
the teamsters and st louis and many
other places in fact
uh and also included some dedicated
gangsters uh people whom he had who he
thought uh make alliances with also uh
and indeed did so now there's no crime
being in the closest of terms with some
major league gangsters which these guys
in many cases were but obviously it
leaves open uh questions of uh
of responsibility and and good taste
with that setup we'll point out that uh
we'll be with uh professor arthur sloan
for about a half an hour more maybe 35
minutes or so we're going to learn about
the life of
james hoffa the teamsters uh leader and
um we're going to take your calls in
just a moment and we want to point out
that we're going to do the phone lines
just a little bit differently today for
this segment
the first line is for folks living in
the east and central time zones 202 737
triple 002 out west it's 202 737 triple
zero one they're all asleep
you'd be surprised a lot of them are
awake and i'm sure many of them are now
but uh union members on the bottom line
202 628-0205 we welcome your comments
and questions for professor sloane as
well this is his book it's titled hoffa
by arthur a sloan this came out in what
year 1991 with a uh when you've got the
paperback 92. and you point out that you
had some interesting access way back
when i
and uh he was uh
hoffa was very open uh although he
tended to express himself kind of warily
at many points and uh and often could go
into uh some tirades against uh not only
professors but
media people really to the end he
nonetheless was extremely open i was a
just a doctoral student in search of a
dissertation topic when i met him in the
uh
in the mid 1960s and all i could get was
half an hour interview with him thanks
to my major professor
james j healey
at the harvard business school and i had
to convert that and it was sheer luck
that i did
and could into an invitation to follow
him around for the better part of four
months so i really did see him
and that got me
my doctorate since the dissertation is
the last step in that as you know
normally i guess at most schools anyhow
years later after every semester i had
given a
a one class office summary and we're
speaking of going into the late 80s and
into the 90s on jimmy hoffa years after
he vanished
and finding that
that students and my students have
generally been 21 years old seniors also
mba students somewhat older but uh none
of whom by and large were around when
hoffo ran the union
finding that uh it was a topic that
fascinated
i suppose thanks
to
jay leno and david letterman and
saturday night live and mad magazine uh
and not the kind of thing that thrills
the harper family necessarily an example
of the genre
uh do you know the answer to this paul
who's the last person
ever to see jimmy hoffa
and the answer is at least in one
version of all this jacques cousteau he
sleeps with the fishes so to speak uh
jim hoffa james philippa
doesn't like that kind of humor
understandably and says it's about the
same as uh other than that how did you
enjoy the play mrs lincoln but in point
of fact
it seemed like book material professors
are expected to write and i had this uh
this enormous investment going way back
of course but i still had kept my
contacts and i had a sabbatical coming
and in 1989 into 1990
i had a uh
the good luck to go out in the field
and talk to uh really everybody still
around an amazing number of people
uh were still around who knew hoffa well
hoffa would be 88 years old if he were
still living
and yet even now 2001 uh quite a few of
his contemporaries who grew up with him
and knew him well are still around and i
talked to all of them and the result
ultimately was the uh was the book that
you referred to let's go to the phones
for our guest uh professor arthur sloane
author of hoffa huntington new york
you're up first go ahead please oh thank
you very much and professor sloan
i just wanted to ask you
the famous
fight or should i say
enmity between robert kennedy and
hafa
did that have anything to do with the
deal that was made by nixon in releasing
him and what were the secret parts of
the deals uh did that eminency their
mutual hate of the the candidates have
anything to do with uh
halfway getting that pardon
well it's really a two-part question a
very good question certainly what do i
look for look at the screen or look at
you or uh well thank you straight ahead
okay you're welcome to look right there
go ahead
uh very good question uh
why did the kennedys and specifically
robert f kennedy uh feel so much enmity
uh uh toured jimmy hoffa there's no
clear answer but it's widely believed
that there were several parts to the
answer uh one that uh as
counsel to the mcclellan committee and a
very young guy
at that point born in 1925
uh bobby kennedy in the 1957 1959 period
when the committee had its widely
watched televised hearings
uh felt that there were some political
uh opportunities for himself here uh
even in his early thirties he many
people believed aspired to perhaps being
governor of massachusetts uh and uh uh
being seen as uh
against a conspiracy of evil which uh
kennedy often referred to uh
hoffa as uh running certainly couldn't
hurt him he was also of course
a very loyal
younger brother uh and in the 57-59
period his uh older brother
jack a senator at that point uh
was uh clearly a candidate for the uh
presidency and once again political
mileage could be gained but the biggest
reason most people who have looked into
this
much more
closely than i have are convinced
existed was the fact that
robert kennedy genuinely saw
bad in hoffa he saw him as a bad citizen
uh he saw him as a force uh to be taken
on and overcome uh and uh in so doing uh
virtue would uh be triumphant uh
needless to say robert kennedy and john
f kennedy were not the closest friends
to uh richard nixon to go on to the
second part of your
question
when
hoffa came out of jail on december 23
1971
after four years
nine months and some 16 days in the
lewisburg pennsylvania penitentiary
he
signed a parole agreement as all people
come out of jail
must do
and only uh uh some weeks later
discovered uh that the agreement
supposedly he claimed it was not on his
copy of the agreement said that he could
not run for the uh for any teamster
office and of course specifically the
teams to presidency until 1980.
uh he said he never would have signed
the agreement the union to him was
except only for his family his whole
life uh and uh
his lawyers and he had many at his
disposal
found
themselves a a violation or claim to
find a violation of the first fourth and
fifth amendment in such a restriction
his hand-picked hoffa's hand-picked
successor as head of the teamsters
frankfurt simmons had been a major
contributor to richard nixon's campaign
in 1968
as he was to be again
in 1972 presidential campaign
and a lot of people believe that
fitz and nixon struck this deal to keep
uh hoffa out
hoffa was so popular that had he run
again had he been free to run again
he undoubtedly would have sailed through
fitzsimmons was not a popular president
he was known as a
peanut butter sandwich in teamster
terminology uh not a good speaker unlike
hoffa who was a charismatic speaker they
used to say that fitz can empty a room
in nothing flat and in fact he preferred
to go out and play golf primarily
and allow the mob to get its hooks
rather deeply into
the teamster
employer pension and also health and
welfare uh funds
which is uh in fact because uh in
1976 the presidential election uh would
be held hoffa had the parole restriction
uh been removed would have been free to
run
as i say would have sailed through
the mob did not want harper to come back
hoffa hoffa could easily say no to the
mob as well as yesterday bob he was very
fearless he was very unpredictable fitz
could only say yes to the bob he was the
preferred guy and
word went out supposedly widely believed
to
make sure that hoffa cannot come back
his presidency especially since it
looked as though he would be able to uh
in 1976 uh and in fact uh in the most
widely held and indeed the fbi uh
version of what happened to ahafa uh the
genovese family which is the one most
threatened by uh hoffa's possible return
did in fact uh
garat him a couple of hit men three hit
men probably
in
as he sat in the front seat of a
pontiac granville
automobile in bloomfield township
michigan and there's a picture of it on
the screen now in fact that picture was
taken the very next day
namely july 31st 1975 the day after
hoffa vanished and was immediately by
most tougher watches uh believed to have
been killed he was in fact believed
in the version to have been garrotted
you know what garad it is
paul i didn't either i had to look it up
but strangled in the car
uh and in a long nutshell that's no
nutshell actually uh those are the
answers to the two questions let's get
some more calls in for our guest arthur
sloan uh long island new york i
understand we have a union member on the
line good morning good morning good
morning professor sloan good morning i
would like to talk about two unions one
which you probably know very well the
aaup
the union for university professors
and then the nea i belong to both unions
now what i find interesting is when i
was a young man some 40 years ago
i began as a university professor
and nice line of work excuse me a nice
line of work like nice line of work
but i found out that a public school
teacher on long island was making a
hundred percent more money than i as a
university i can believe that too okay
so what i did
was i ended my career as a full-time
college professor
became a public school teacher i became
a full-time public school teacher and
remain as an adjunct professor for the
rest of my life
now what i'm really trying to get to is
this
on brain power alone and education you
would think that the
university professor
should demand more money but to show you
the skewed
situation which the marketplace is put
into by a union the nea being much more
powerful than the aaup
i ended my career
in
teaching out here on long island and i
have a very good pension i was paid very
well
but i really enjoyed my part-time job
which began around three o'clock in the
afternoon as an adjunct professor and
remained for that same period of time as
an adjunct professor what i'm really
trying to get to is
the strength and of a union sometimes
skews
your worth and although i loved both
public school teaching i was a senior
high school teacher
of economics and i taught industrial
relations by the way at the university
thanks
he made this point at the end there did
you agree with that yes that the
strength of the unions sometimes excuse
things absolutely but unions make no
pretense about it and that's why as a
general statement i certainly is a
complete neutral don't speak for unions
but as a general statement uh unions
would like to organize everybody so that
there'd be no disparities and back to
jimmy hoffa's work with the teamsters
what did his work and and his legacy the
legacy of his work what did that mean to
other unions as the years went on and
their strength well i think there were
two parts of the jimmy hoffa legacy uh
one
as i alluded to briefly before
not so briefly
is that he stabilized a formerly
dog-eat-dog industry and that industry
happened to be the most important by
many standards it still is
industry in the united states he
injected a great deal of economic health
and hence both the
the teamsters and the employers
were very much in his uh cheering
section
as a labor leader in other words he uh
his legacy was a very good one
in many ways a model for other labor
leaders on the other hand the negative
has to come in here obviously uh and his
legacy also is that the name hoffa
is remembered most people
have heard of no other labor leader but
jimmy hoffa they couldn't name they
couldn't identify people that you've had
on c-span that has the series i
understand samuel gompers and mother
jones proceeded george meaney maybe is
coming up they they have never heard of
any of these possibly mother because of
the magazine but nothing else but hoffa
they have heard of and uh in many ways
in a negative way well there are a lot
of people who especially because of the
1992 jack nicholson danny devito movie
which uh i thought had some superb
acting as you'd expect and some very
good parts but
uh despite the disclaimer that it was
not faithful to the facts it made no
pretense of being
is the uh aspect of hoffa that many
people remember hoffa was viewed as a
kind of a unidimensional power hungry
criminal and his legacy to this day i
think
is that here was this most powerful
labor leader ever
years after he vanished 26 years three
weeks ago after he vanished
still gives i think the labor movement a
black eye when people
say what they don't like about unions
you hear words like feather bedding and
you hear words like hoffa
house new mexico for professor arthur
sloan the topic jimmy hop up good
morning
hi good morning sir
i was wondering if you ever came across
a colleague of mine in the in the course
of your
preparing your article uh frank
dandridge photographer for
um for life magazine who spent quite a
bit of time uh photographing
um
i heard about frank dandridge i cannot
recall uh ever meeting him caller
thank you we know what jimmy hoffa
looked like what did he sound like what
would it have been like if you met him
in a room and shook his hand how did he
run a meeting uh he was uh
surprisingly
short five five and a half 170 pounds
all muscle
but
very very charismatic
he ran a meeting and he was the boss no
question about it he uh
he murdered the english language a lot
of ants and don'ts although he had
pre-improved appreciably over the years
uh in that respect uh but uh his i think
intelligence and his knowledge of uh
what he was talking about the trucking
industry teamster affairs in general uh
was so uh uh clear
that uh he had to get uh total respect
and indeed he did uh
he had
rounds of applause
almost every time he
finished a paragraph at many meetings
and he was very proud of that
next week we will focus on george meaney
as we continue with our series on labor
uh clearwater florida another union
member good morning welcome to you
uh thank you
you're on the air oh am i on air yes sir
okay
yes uh
i like to explain why uh i know jimmy
hoffer in
1953 when i went
in the service
and he told me
when i come back out of the service
he would see that my job was
there when i got back and did he
oh yes when i got back i had a little
problem then i called him up he gave me
his
private phone yeah and when i called him
up
he gave me uh
he said i'll have a settle right away he
told me to go down i have my seniority
back
and he made sure everything was right
yes i'm not surprised he did that for
hundreds thousands of people really was
very proud of it
oh yeah
you still there yes i am oh i think we i
think we just popped up another caller
is it delavan wisconsin taliban
wisconsin go ahead delevan
go ahead
you're on the air i'm on the air yes
but professor sloan am i talking to you
now yes you are okay
i've i've muted i um i'm looking at your
face
but i had occasion when i first got out
of law school back in 1951
to work with an attorney by the name of
bob johnstone
who
was at the end of his career
and he subsequently died just a year or
two after that but he was representing a
man in prison by that time by the name
of roger tui
who was the man that al capone had
framed into a
uh
what he had framed him and put him in
prison and a federal judge actually did
release him bob johnstone died before he
actually saw that
but two he owned a trucking firm and was
very much involved in trucking
and he had as
an enemy of course al capone and the
uh it was known as kieshan trucking
which was taken over
and subsequently
uh keishan i believe was very active in
the uh kingsters union
uh well if you had occasion to run into
that in your research yes uh not just
research but i met people from keisha
the that company back in the mid 60s
when i did the original uh following
offer around research was uh
picked by
the employers and there were 16 thousand
of them and they regularly chose
depending on the purpose eight to ten
uh of their colleagues to uh represent
them keishan was often one of them
chosen to represent uh the interest i
think of some of the smaller tracking
companies
15 minutes left with our guest professor
arthur sloan who has written this book
hoffa we'll continue to take your calls
as we look at the front cover
of uh this book here talk about jimmy
hoffa's early life who were his greatest
influences how do you grow up
half a born in 1913
his dad was an itinerant coal driller
and working out of brazil indiana and
south central
indiana
uh but the dad
died in 1920 when hoffa was just seven
years old
and uh not all that much later just a
very few years later hoffa was uh forced
by the impoverishment of his mother uh
who was taking care of four children
half of being the third of four children
to drop out of school
uh and go to work
there is a question as to whether or not
this was the seventh grade or the ninth
grade uh hoffa's official biography
which is a uh
uh no longer available in a 16-page
brochure really put out by the teamsters
and widely circulated uh in hoffa's era
says that uh jim had uh nine years of
schooling and uh never went on had to
drop out
uh and i checked that with him as i had
to check everything with him and said
you had nine years of schooling i can
still see the little sly smile that uh
played across off his face he said i
never had no nine years of schooling he
said i had seven years of schooling that
was just some sharp public relations guy
trying to make me look educated hoffa
did have a sense of humor uh a little
bit pie in the face he wouldn't be
confused with pg woodhouse or anything
but uh
he liked the kid around he uh one of his
favorite jokes was uh uh what's uh the
most popular soup in america and the
answer and he he loved to spring this on
people was uh souped as yours on every
menu uh he he wasn't fully kidding
though uh when he uh
said that his two uh favorite mottos and
he regularly
used both of these one is every man has
his price no humor intended there that
got him into trouble i think with above
all that credo
with the jury tampering
but also and here there was some humor
intended but also some seriousness do
unto others first
i his mother then moved the family to to
detroit which was uh blossoming with the
growth of the automobile industry took a
variety of the jobs and hoffa who could
pass for somewhat older than he was when
he was 16 he could pass for 18. uh
worked at the kroger's warehouse uh on
the uh in the west side of uh detroit uh
and uh
one day uh led his co-workers although
he was younger than uh than most of them
on a uh
on a
strike just as a load of perishable
strawberries came in uh and in fact uh
obviously the strawberries would have
spoiled the management krogers gave in
it was an unprecedented victory for that
day and uh hoffa never looked back he uh
in so doing he caught the eye uh of the
afl our confederation of labor uh one of
whose
units was
the international brotherhood of
teamsters and
he was appointed
organizer for joint council 43
of the teamsters in detroit
and from there simply advanced really on
merit and pragmatism he made his
alliances where he had to make him uh
not always the most savory of characters
certainly
he turned to what was called
the east side crowd uh in detroit for
protection uh against uh what he called
excuse me hired thugs one good clearing
of the throne will do this
the higher thugs who
were out to get us
meaning cio people because the afl and
sale were separate
cio thugs according to the hoffa version
at least
an employer hired thugs employers
playing the game too trying to keep out
unions
i've talked to quite a few of uh hoffa's
colleagues from that era who
participated in
some of the fist fights
of that era was a different era uh a
couple of them pointed out they uh they
only used their fists it was considered
a badge of shame if you use anything
else although one of them added once in
a while maybe a baseball bat we are
going to move on to reno nevada for
arthur sloane the topic jimmy hoffa down
to about 10 minutes left
go ahead
reno nevada
know you there i think we lost reno
let's move on to baltimore hello good
morning union member correct yes i am go
ahead sir um mr sloan you've done a
wonderful job
in uh illuminating mr hoffa and what his
life and works were about
i have a question though
i'd like to know what his relationship
with was with a phillip randolph
of the national brotherhood of sleeping
car porters
when
mr randolph came before the afl cio
i think at that time headed by walter
ruther and john l lewis
for inclusion in that organization i'll
hang up and listen to your response
i don't think he had
much of a relationship with him uh
frankly uh uh
the uh hoffa at his uh peak uh was
outside the afl and then the afl-cio
was thrown out in 1957 the teamsters
were thrown out i know that hoffa had
enormous respect for randolph as as
everyone did i think but as far as any
real relationship with him uh if he had
anything of consequence it's unknown to
me
macomb illinois go ahead mccomb
yes um i was greatly influenced by my
stepfather who was that very active in
politics and the local union uaw in fact
as growing up
and i'm a 37 year old male and i might
be wrong in numbers but uh
i believe in jimmy hoffa's era maybe 35
percent of the american workers were
belong to unions
around the button and i think it's
dropped down to the very low teens at
this time yes that's right
do you see anybody in the near future
who might be greatly influenced like
jimmy hoffa who might bring up the ranks
again in the uh
in that area
all across the union board thank you
caller thank you well you never say
never but uh hoffa was suey generous
alpha was absolutely unique i i don't
think that level of uh charisma
intelligence and ability is going to be
approached soon but i wouldn't sell john
j sweeney short i think he's done a
pretty good job
in his uh
now five years at the helm
certainly the hemorrhaging
in union membership has essentially
stopped
a lot of effort has been uh
employed now in organizing which had
been completely neglected for many many
years and also in
augmenting labor's political clout
and i suspect that the years ahead we'll
see a little bit of gain at least by
organized labor but as far as
individuals
there's nobody like hoffa on the horizon
here is a photo of james and josephine
with their four and a half month old
daughter barbara in michigan in 1938
tell us about a little bit more about
the family you touched on it earlier but
uh talked about an impressive family i
think josephine was very different that
is the wife from uh
james r and uh
maybe it's uh that that made them uh uh
so close uh she was playful
uh fun-loving uh a very devoted uh wife
and a very uh
good mother uh a family that brought
both of them a lot of pride the daughter
barbara born in 1938
uh
was a
phi beta kappa graduate of
albion college in michigan
uh was a first grade school teacher for
a while but decided that she'd like to
follow her younger brother at that
point he had been an established lawyer
for a while looked like a pretty good
life and
in her 40s she went back to school got
her law degree in st louis
and is today a judge a highly respected
judge uh in missouri
the son james p
current president of the
teamsters
was an all-state football player
in
detroit from detroit in michigan went on
to the uh
to michigan state
uh actually
was going to play football at least
tri-do for the legendary coach duffy
doherty and very likely could have made
the squad despite the fact that he's
certainly not big ten caliber as far as
height or weight maybe ability too but
it looked as though he was going to make
it when his dad said
i didn't send you to college to play
football either hit the books or don't
count on me to pay
and so jim took the hint
hit the books did very well
and went on to the university of
michigan law school i was a practicing
lawyer for many years before he decided
he'd take a try at the team's presidency
and how does he compare with his father
do you think in terms of his teamsters
presidency nobody compares with uh james
r hoff as far as charisma jim is a
certainly uh a very uh able guy
but he's the new breed of labor leader
he talks the way you'd expect a uh a law
school graduate to talk he's uh he's
bright but nobody i think had the
intelligence of his dad including uh any
professor i've ever met his dad was
brilliant by the way what is the
teamster where'd the term come from
teamster uh
when the union was founded in 1899 uh or
1903 opinions differ as to when it
actually uh uh was officially
established
with drivers of teams of horses there
being no trucks or anything like it of
course in those days
and that's where the name came from
let's go to uh island kentucky for
arthur sloan good morning good morning
uh i want to ask mr sloan about the
connection with uh john l lewis and
harper
i'm a
united mine worker uh
working the mine 35 years and uh i've
talked i met john l back in the 50s and
everything and i never did hear him say
very much good for
hoffa could you comment on that
well hoffa was a much uh a younger guy
than lewis and really had not uh
hit the pinnacle of power uh in all but
the very closing days of of lewis's uh
life there was a a great deal of amnity
between
jimmy hoffa and denny lewis john l
lewis's younger brother and in fact
denny was entrusted uh with uh
keeping out teamster influence uh which
of course was afl influence not cio
influence uh in uh the uh 40s and early
50s uh in detroit and that's where those
uh fist battles uh once in that extreme
situation maybe the baseball bat battles
uh took place and it was in fact the
denny lewis people against the jimmy
hoffa people
last call for this segment topeka kansas
another union member you're on with
arthur sloane talking about james huffa
go ahead
thank you very much good morning
professor good morning and thank you for
c-span welcome um i'd like
i didn't mean that it's not mine
you're welcome from both of us go ahead
i'd like the professor to talk about the
economic impact of of unions of
of jimmy hoffa how
the union member made
more money made
had better benefits
and to this day some of them union
members are still
getting a great pinch and
yes something we touched on at the top
of the show but the impact of his work
hoffa was very proud
hoffa was very proud of uh of the
pension uh as well as everything else
and in fact uh in his uh male and wire
fraud trial
1964 uh his lawyers tried to introduce
the fact that the pensions compared so
favorably uh to uh other unionist
pensions uh and that uh
the percentage of uh bad loans made for
the funds was much lower than the norm
uh and that the pensions had the fund
itself had grown to uh 400 million in
hoffa's last four years before going to
jail uh
a four-fold uh uh increase that uh
information was not allowed by the judge
but they were very proud
of the record and at least tried to uh
introduce it
wages and conditions uh similarly uh did
uh stood very very uh well depending on
the part of the country because what
hoffa did was aim for a nationwide
uniform trucking contract putting a half
a million in his day
over the road and local cartage truckers
under one contract thus it depended on
what part of the country you were
talking about as this in fact came to
fruition uh in january 1967 hopper did
achieve just before he went off to jail
what he had been shooting for for years
consequently if you're speaking about
a a southern local
uh you're speaking of over
a matter of a very few years a tripling
of wages and a commensurate improvement
in uh benefits and and uh conditions if
you're speaking of new york city or
chicago uh or san francisco uh somewhat
less but then in all cases a good
doubling of them
professor arthur a sloan author of hoffa
appreciate your time this morning
pleasure paul thanks for having me and
we thank everyone who uh phoned in there
in this three hour show i want to remind
folks that uh today at one o'clock
eastern time three hours from now we
will have a live coverage from out in
california at the blessed sacrament
cathedral in sacramento for the memorial
service maureen reagan
uh speakers include the actor david hyde
pierce the president of the republic of
uganda california's first lady sharon
davis will be there epa administrator
christy todd whitman senator john mccain
also expected the memorial service for
maureen reagan today one o'clock eastern
time today live here on c-span and we'll
be back with another edition of this
program tomorrow at seven o'clock our
guests include deborah mathis a
syndicated columnist also john fund of
the wall street journal we hope you
enjoy the rest of your day and your
weekend
[Music]
nathaniel mackey is this year's winner
of the award for poetry a literature
professor at the university of
california in santa cruz he also writes
fiction and literary criticism his
winning entry is splays anthem
and rounding out the awards is the young
people's literature prize winner mt
anderson his book the astonishing life
of octavian nothing volume 1 describes
an african-american boy raised as part
of an experiment to test the intellect
of african-americans during the
revolutionary war it's the first in a
two-part series
winners of the national book award
receive ten thousand dollars and a
crystal sculpture
for more information visit the national
book foundation website at
nationalbook.org
next karen mclaughlin frist wife of
senate majority leader bill frist
she shares her new collection of stories
written by women about their fathers it
includes entries by former first lady
barbara bush and condoleezza rice
this is 40 minutes
thank you
[Applause]
well this is an honor for me a long way
from nashville tennessee and a long way
from washington d.c
to be able to introduce my dear wife
and i'll have to start and go back to
about a year ago
and i'd come home after closing down the
senate late at night
i'm always the first person there in the
morning and i usually the last person at
night as a majority leader because you
open the senate then you close it down
and so i get home at about 10 o'clock or
10 30 at night
and i get ready and brush my teeth and
get ready to go to bed climb into bed
and i say karen
karen in the room next door
which is where our computer is out here
and i say karen's time to go to bed
it's about a year a year and a half ago
and it'd be karen and i said karen what
in the world are you doing
and she said you'll see you'll see
and indeed this this this project but
really this new child this birth which
karen's going to be talking about here
called love you daddy boy began not just
a year ago but about three years ago it
has nothing to do with politics it has
nothing to do with being a republican or
a democrat
it has nothing to do with what i did for
20 years and which karen and i have
partnered in doing and that is
practicing medicine
that healing profession
but it had to do with what you will hear
a little bit about here in just a few
minutes
karen and i uh
have been married in 1981 so i was
getting ready to add up about how many
years 20.
25 years karen's a native of lubbock
texas
uh has a sister and that's
that's key because somewhere in there
that relationship between those two
daughters and their father
i'm sure started as a little nugget of
this book
and i'll have to jump ahead that we've
got three children but they're all three
boys
and therefore that relationship between
daughter and dad i have not yet had
but by reading this 75 how many
different things
70 different stories my eyes have have
been opened i've been blessed to be
married to karen we do have three boys
harris and jonathan and brian they are
very proud as i am and their mom now the
compiler the editor the author join me
in welcoming my wife karen frist
[Applause]
thank you bill roll reversal is here
now i'm talking and he he introduced me
so this is something new for me but
it's great being here and i i have to
say that
i do have 70 chapters all written by
women i didn't interview them and and
have them write them they wrote them
themselves and i was if i'm in a city
where there's a contributor i asked that
contributor to join me
and she signs
her chapter along with me and i was with
barbara bush at the bush library last
week
and she said the first thing you need to
say
is that the book goes to charity so i'm
going to say that now so i don't forget
in case she's watching
i chose three charities the first one is
operation eagles nest which is an org a
foundation
for our military families in fort
campbell the second is as child help usa
which is a organization to combat child
abuse and child neglect and the third
is
autism speaks
which is a foundation to raise awareness
for autism and when i was in austin
texas last week i actually had someone
in the audience raise their hand and ask
what autism was
so hopefully this book is which i
explained i'm a former special education
teacher so hopefully this book is
achieving
one of my goals of raising awareness for
autism
but someone once said that any man can
be a father but it takes a very special
man to be a dad or daddy as i call him
and these are all very daddy stories and
my father actually bill asked me to
marry him here in new hampshire not too
far from here and i was thinking in the
old-fashioned way he asked daddy first
and then the next morning at breakfast
he gave me the engagement ring but
i thought today gosh would we have ever
dreamt that
26 years later we would be in new
hampshire and there would be a story
written about my father so that's
that's pretty ironic as far as i'm
concerned
i got so i the the initial thought was
just to honor my own father who died 23
years ago
but then then after that of course i
wanted to do that ephesians six one
through four says honor your father and
mother so i've always wanted to do
something to honor him
but i got the idea about three years ago
president bush was introducing then
national security adviser condoleezza
rice
and she's such a stoic woman and shows
so little emotion
and when the president said your father
would be proud of you
her lower lip quivered a little bit
and she almost
lost her composure at just the mere
mention of this man that she loves so
much
and this man who had really encouraged
her to reach for her highest star and of
course she certainly has grabbed it and
then later i spoke to her and when she
became secretary of state of course i
thought i'd never get her story
but one night actually in that i did it
all from our an office off of our
bedroom i heard the fax machine at about
three o'clock in the morning and my fax
machine started and condi's story which
was hand written came across my fax
machine so i pictured her up in an
airplane flying to meet some world
leader
and taking a pen and piece of paper out
and reflecting on her father
then later a couple of months later we
were in the white house
for a reception for the pres the king of
spain
and we were all standing at our our
places and there was one empty seat and
the president who's extremely punctual
was very irritated that there was one
person who wasn't there
and we heard running down the hall and
in ran this beautiful blonde woman jenna
bush and when he saw her his face just
melted and he suddenly
could have cared less that the king of
spain and everyone in the room had been
held a little bit late
waiting for her to arrive
and that night sandra day o'connor was
actually sitting at my table and i
looked over at her and
she said did you see that reaction by
the president and i said yes i did
so the next morning i called sandra day
o'connor in her supreme court
chamber and i was really nervous to call
her i had known her just socially but to
me she was such a powerful woman the
first woman of course on the supreme
court
and she answered the phone in a low
voice supreme court justice o'connor
and my voice was up so high because i
was so nervous
and i'd we talked a little bit about the
night before well we ended up talking
for 45 minutes and by the end of the
conversation her voice too was about
four octaves higher just talking about
her dad
and she told a wonderful story about
she was to deliver um
lunch to the ranch hands when she was 14
she grew up in arizona
and she had a flat tire and
she worked hard to change the tire the
lugs had rusted so she actually had to
jump on the jack to get the flat tire
changed and she was so proud of herself
she was an hour and a half late but she
really thought her father would just be
thrilled
well he wasn't he said you should have
allowed more time you need to be held
accountable for your actions
and so she was determined for the rest
of her life to do just that
so maybe that one moment was catapulted
her into the drive to become the first
woman on the supreme court
and i also learned a story in the the
book about bill's father because his
sister wrote a chapter for the book
he um she writes and i knew bill's
father who was a physician in nashville
for over 27 years
but she writes about her father and
bill's father used to kneel with them at
bedtime and tell and say their prayers
and he said
god doesn't listen to a lazy man's
prayers and i never knew that so that
picture of this
norman rockwell six foot five doctor on
bended knee with his
five little children was just a moment
that i'm sure was very special in her
memory
the title is love you daddy boy and it's
titled that because my father wrote me
every monday in college and he signed
his letters love you daddy boy
so that's where the title came from i
went to tcu in fort worth and last week
i stopped by the tcu campus and a lot of
the students came out and i even went by
my old dorm and
and went into katie anderson's room from
lufkin texas i still haven't called her
back and the chancellor was with me and
we took some pictures and lo and behold
there was a picture of katie and her
father
so i'm going to send her a copy of my
book
in the back of the book there is a place
that you can write a chapter about your
own
father and put a picture and give it to
your dad for christmas
so it's a great christmas gift as some
of you have been talking about is under
twenty dollars the proceeds go to
charity
and you can write a place in the back
about your own father
many women said i've always wanted to
talk about my father uh senator kay
bailey hutchison said
i always had it written into my speeches
but i'd get a lump in my throat and i
just couldn't say it when it came to
that so you've provided me a pla
venues that i can write about my father
but the um i do have daughters of i
don't want to say famous people because
my father was the most famous person in
the world but you don't have never heard
of him so i say recognizable names i
have daughters of jimmy hoffa
johnny cash billy graham nolan ryan cal
ripken
nascar driver daryl waltrip it's not
just a political book
and then i what i did was i divided
into five categories
politics of course because that's the
waters that i'm swimming in right now
and i do have democrats
i have kathleen kennedy townsend hillary
clinton
dianne feinstein the senator from
california
john glenn the astronaut senator's
daughter wrote a wonderful story
president lbj
daughter wrote a story
and then i also have women in business
entertainment such as bo derek barbara
mandrell amy grant
and an education and
columnist such as cokie roberts
margaret thatcher wrote a chapter
and
the amazing thing of all of these people
i have 10 countries represented that
there is a common theme
that no matter how fleeting life is many
of these women lost their fathers when
they were young but the common theme is
our fathers do give us a foundation for
life and many women use the word
foundation the anchor in our life
elizabeth dole said my father
gave me a blueprint of moral values to
lead my life
but i would like to
read a little bit if that's okay from a
couple of chapters
barbara bush said next to my husband
marvin pierce was the most decent man
i've ever met
daddy told me sometime in that period
growing up that there were only three
things you really should give your
children
the best education set a good example
and all the love in the world
and then i might add a fourth that
george bush has taught me trust your
children set them free and give them
independence i had the very best father
ever
elaine chao who was the
first she's of course our secretary of
labor right now
her father moved here from taiwan after
the civil war in china she moved he
moved here three years before his family
and she says
her parents made
their dream come true my father arrived
in america first it took him three long
years before he could bring my mother
sisters and me to the united states
during the those years of separation he
and my mother communicated only through
letters
yet their love remained steadfast
when my mother sisters and i finally
arrived in america i entered the third
grade not speaking a word of english
every day i copied whatever was on the
blackboard onto my notebook
every night after his long and
exhausting day of work
my father sat with me at the kitchen
table
trying to decipher my childish scribbles
so he could explain the day's lessons to
me and that's how i learned english dad
was patient loving and tireless
as he and my mother built a new life for
our family in this great country
another thing i ask every woman to do is
to send in some
photographs
and the photographs are priceless johnny
cash's daughter roseanne sent a
photograph in
of herself sitting on her father's lap
possibly when she was five years old in
memphis and then the second photograph
was probably months before he passed
away
and of course coming from tennessee we
all have heard johnny cash stories she
wrote some very touching moments about
when she would go and meet with him and
he would they would read the bible
together proverbs and psalms and listen
to cnn news and debate politics
clinton of course most of your viewers
know that her father was republican and
they disagreed a lot on some different
issues but then came together at the end
and he of course supported her
nadia comaneci which was grew up in
communist romania
her father would work he was an auto
mechanic
and he would walk over 12 miles to and
from work to teach her the high work
ethic because he wanted to provide her
with
as much as he possibly could
to this day people still ask me about
scoring the perfect 10 of the olympics
and yes it was exciting but it was
merely the result of the hard work and
dedication that i learned from my father
jimmy hoffa's daughter barbara krantzer
is a judge in missouri
she starts off her chapter by saying at
7 30
a.m on july 31 1975 i answered the
telephone to hear my mother say your
father did not come home last night i
knew at that moment that i would never
see my father again
after a frantic few hours i sank into
the seat of my airplane seat and closed
my eyes
i had a vision of my father dressed in
dark pants and a short sleeved shirt
his body was slumped over as if
dead i had no way of knowing that these
were the exact clothes that he wore the
day he disappeared
i flew to detroit to take care of my
mother just as he had always told me to
do
we all know that about jimmy hoffa but
we don't know
the tender moments that he he had with
his daughter
one of the first lessons i remember is
having the job of placing long distance
phone calls from our home
this week required speaking to the
operator to tell her the phone number
and the person to whom my father was
wishing to speak to
when the person came online i was taught
to say in a good little girl voice
please hold for mr hoffa
in this way mister my father taught me
to be comfortable speaking to others
and then he danced with her at her
wedding and wore a tuxedo for the first
time and those things we don't know
about jimmy hoffa
as i've said elizabeth dole writes that
her father
provided the blueprint for life
this strong godly compassionate man my
beloved father set the course of my life
his gifts are still with me they'll be
with me forever
as i said that if i have a contributor
in the city the the woman and sometimes
even her father joins me and last week i
was in dallas
and with nancy perrault mulford and
lo and behold ross perot surprised her
and came to the book signing
and so
she read her chapter and she says
she felt the feeling of security and
being absolutely awash in love and
affection the day that she rode on a
horse with ross perot and he wrapped his
arms around her for comfort
my childhood was magical
he taught me how much difference one
individual can make and the importance
of keeping religion christian principles
at the center of my life
i hope to never disappoint him
so there was nancy perot in a bookstore
in dallas texas and her father was in
the audience just hanging on to every
word
i've mentioned nancy reagan she found a
just as if as i said my father wrote me
letters she found a letter her father
wrote to her in college she found it 65
later years later in the very bottom of
a box
and she says i encourage everyone to
save letters sent to them by their
parents
one day they will be truly uh treasured
president johnson this is a great
picture of president johnson he called
his daughter the three d's
darling
daddy's darling daughter
and she talks about him dressing up as
santa claus and riding the tractor
around the ranch in texas and then she
closes with
one of my most treasured photos of my
father is not one with him and me but
one of him with
my two oldest girls snuggling in his
arms as he sits in his comfortable
recliner reading the night before
christmas to them something he never had
time to do for me
i mentioned margaret thatcher her father
always wanted to be a teacher but
because of
different things in his family he had to
drop out of school at age 13.
but he had a passion for reading and
self-improvement
so as a young girl he would take her to
the local library and get her two books
a history and a biography
a history or a biography and one on
poetry or literature
both books had to be read during the
week and before they returned to my
father we would just
discuss each of them with me to assert
my opinions and see what i had learned
and of course she later became the first
woman prime minister
then one of my very favorites is
kathleen kennedy townsend
and she has a wonderful picture of
herself and her father
and then here's a picture of her with
all of her siblings
and i chose her because most of you know
she was
she was the lieutenant governor of
maryland
but she said when my father when my
brothers when my father's brother died
my father taught us how to live despite
his terrible sadness and sense of loss
he knew that he had a role to play that
he could not give up and he had a strong
sense of responsibility
and he would always say to them do you
know how lucky you are and that you have
a responsibility to our country and that
was kathleen kennedy townsend
the stories go on and on and on and
they're just um
they are very heartwarming and i hope
that you'll enjoy the book i'd love to
answer any questions if you have
any questions for me and um i hope that
you've enjoyed it
i heard there's a story about
a father and daughter and 9 11.
yes
people often ask me what my favorite
story is and it's it's almost like your
children you know they ask you
am i your favorite child and i always
say well you're my favorite oldest son
or you're my favorite youngest son to
kind of hedge the question
but i think possibly the favorite my
favorite chapter in the book that means
the most to me is a name that you might
not recognize her name is kelly garcia
ariaga and her father died on flight 93
on september 11th
and the reason that it means so much to
me is of course i feel that that plane
could possibly be have been headed
towards well probably was headed towards
the united states capital
and our children's
father's life was saved as a result of
the heroism of
of her father
and she doesn't dwell on that in her
story she really ironically enough they
have had a love for flying and
they both were private pilots and he
used to take her outside and and not let
her look up to the sky and ask her to
guess what what airplane was flying over
and she could usually guess it by the
sound of the engine so she doesn't dwell
on how he died but then at the very end
i have a bio on each person and at the
very end she says that her father was
one of the heroes on flight 93
so that possibly is my very very
favorite chapter
so many people have special
relationships daughters have special
relationships with their fathers
yet it's not always easy to put it into
words
did you find that you had people that
contributed that really wanted to share
their story but had a hard time writing
it or did most of the people have an
easy time was it something that they
were just ready to share well i did um
some of the contributors wanted to make
a bigger
deal out of what i was actually asking i
really was asking women to open their
hearts
and just tell a simple anecdote about
their father's nothing more and nothing
less and i i used cokey roberts and
nancy reagan's and
president johnson's daughter linda robb
they were some of the first so i would
often fax
samples to these people
but then i i asked them to write 350 to
500 words and you'll see in the book
many of them went way over so once they
started writing they had trouble
stopping
and they're all simple things such as
uh senator john glenn's daughter wrote a
story about of course and
i'm sure she got to do a lot of
wonderful things with her father who was
a senator and an astronaut
but she she chose to wrote to write
about uh
her father gave her a pair of skates
and the first day she was on them she
was barreling down the road she flew off
the road tripped over the curb and cut
her knee and her father in a very
creative way
got an electric fan and plugged it in to
to blow on the the cut on her leg to
ease the paint
and that's the one thing that she wrote
about so
it's often not the expensive gift it's
not the trip that they got to to go on
with their fathers is something so
simple that many of these men probably
didn't even realize they were doing at
the time
any other questions
yes
i was wondering kind of in the minority
here because you've been listening so
intently
um
when these uh stories were coming
through the fax machine or your emails
or however you ended up getting them
what was that the thread that uh
that you would get that would
that you could tell me that would make
me a better father to my daughter well
the thread is that
like i said the foundation that you're
giving your daughter right now by being
at her soccer game by being at a pta
meeting by walking her to school in the
mornings that foundation that you're
giving her really will take her through
life
and
as i said also a lot of these women lost
their their fathers when they were quite
young
i hope that that's right exactly mary
higgins clarke of course who's a
wonderful author
herself she was holding her father's
hand when the hindenburg blew up her
father came here from isle ireland
and to ellis isle island and when he he
died when she was 11 and she said she
still feels that comfort from his hand
when the hindenburg blew up and then he
he later died and she feels
that comfort forever and she has a heart
hunger she says that she will
she wants to feel that security again
i also had a woman say to me you can
almost tell when you meet a woman
if they had a close relationship with
their father because they almost have a
security in themselves
and a confidence that no matter what
happens because there are some stories
in here
gracie rosenberger has a terrible car
accident and has both of her legs
amputated as a result and her father was
there for her through 60 operations
so there are some stories in here that
are very very tragic and very sad
but just be there for your daughters and
you do hear on when children are younger
i think we hear more about the mother's
influence with them
and not the fathers so i hope that this
is a book that men will read in addition
to women
because they're you you do make a
difference in your daughter's life no
matter what background you're coming
from
did you have a question yes um were
there any uh women who didn't get a
chance to contribute for one reason the
other whose stories you would have liked
to have had in the book well um
that is a good question and
life is fleeting in the fact that there
were two women that i wanted to ask rosa
parks
that passed away before i could ever
even find a number to call them
what a story she could have told about
her father and julia childs was another
woman that was on my list that i wanted
to ask
and the same thing happened i had
several fathers die
after the woman agreed to do it coach
pat summitt she's the most winning coach
in the country
she coaches the lady ball volunteer
basketball team in knoxville tennessee
i asked her to do the chapter she was
thrilled she grew up on a farm
and her father taught her that cows
don't take the day off so neither will
you
so she was also raised with a very high
work ethic and you know look what she's
become her father died last year in
december
and she had agreed to do it but i didn't
have the chapter so of course
i was so hesitant to call her
and i finally called because my deadline
was march 1st right at the beginning of
march madness basketball season and she
actually thanked me for calling her and
asking me to to do that dr norman
shumway who bill trained under
at stanford california he was is the
father of heart transplantation her
daughter his daughter is also a heart
transplant surgeon and he also died from
the time that
i asked her to do the story from the
time that
the book was published so there is a
common thread that life is
so fleeting and then we do need to
treasure every moment but there were
several women that
not many that i couldn't actually get to
and ask but there were several that
passed away that i didn't get to ask
yes have you gotten letters from
ordinary people um remember when what's
his name wrote the book tim russell
yes
well i have well of course i get emails
i do have a website that i hope
everybody will go on it's
www.loveyourdaddyboy.com and i have a
daily blog
so i write down what i'm doing every day
and i have received a lot of emails from
you can email me from there so i have
received a lot of those but i've i have
to share a funny story
i had a lot of women saying oh my father
was the most wonderful man in the world
you've got to put my father in your
story in your book
so just saturday i was flying from
austin texas to dallas fort worth and i
was seated next to
a really kind woman
on the airplane and she said well it's
too bad we didn't meet before because i
would have loved to have written the
chapter about my father
so i thought well i'm glad the book's
already out because you know i really
knew who i wanted to ask and she said my
father was walter cronkite
and of course i said well maybe i'll do
a second one and i'll call you first
and so she said may i buy a book for my
dad and give it to him and of course i
said yes ma'am let me have your address
so i'm just so honored to think that
walter cronkite will have a book soon so
i hope he's not listening to this and
then she's going to write a chapter
about him in the back
so
yes clearly these are all personal
stories that daughters have shared with
you
how many of the stories were from women
that you didn't know before the book and
and how many are know your friend well i
probably knew
um half of them before
so i didn't know that many um
i would find someone
that had a connection to them for
instance nolan ryan i'm from texas so
i am in such awe of nolan ryan that even
if i saw him i don't think i could go up
and say hello to him
but a friend of our niece actually
corrine barfield is friends with his
daughter wendy ryan and so that's how i
made the connection there and um
so i haven't i still did the stay have
not met all the contributors nancy
perrault i met her for the first time
um
aj molesko is a woman hockey player she
lives not too far from here in
massachusetts
and her she was on the first olympic
team when the women won the gold medal
in the olympics and i had not met her
and she came to our house not too long
ago i did a party a thank you party for
all the contributors and she came with
her father and it was just such a
wonderful moment having
her and then daryl waltrip's daughters
he's the nascar driver now he's a sports
commentator
that's my youngest contributor sarah
caitlin walter she was 13 when she wrote
the chapter
so seven weeks before a huge election we
had not only kathleen kennedy townsend
and elizabeth dole and condi rice so
democrats and republicans and then we
had dr benjamin hooks
of course he was former naacp ahead and
a nascar driver
cal ripken professional baseball so in
my house in our house it was just so
much fun
and i it probably was the only place in
washington that wasn't talking about
politics that day
and i still hope to um meet all of them
and i mentioned earlier i would love to
do books on tape and have each
contributor read their story juan de
ferragamo
um from
italy she sent her story in in italian
and we had to um interpret it and then i
i kept sending it back and forth because
of course i wanted it to say exactly
what she wanted to say so that would
actually be fun for her chapter to be in
italian and her to read it so maybe that
will be my next project
yes
why um
why a christmas release rather than a
father's day release
well that's a good question and quite
honestly as far as i'm concerned
that's when i got it finished was
what
was march 1st yes exactly
um but it is a book for
fathers and a lot of fathers are buying
it for their daughters and um
even women that
yeah that's right and it's this chapter
exactly
so hopefully it will continue throughout
father's day but my deadline this time
if you can believe it last november i
met with my editor
and he i had seven stories and i was so
proud of myself
and this was my first venture and i will
say my editor is a friend of mine so
he said well if you can get 70 chapters
i think it would be a great book well i
almost fell off my chair because i i was
thinking more like 20 or 30 so
the majority of this has been done over
the last year and
march first is the deadline that he gave
me and
and so i i made only one person
didn't get her chapter in and um
i don't know she may not even know the
book's been published so
but she didn't get it in in time
any other billie jean
king billie jean king um
the wonderful
woman tennis player that went on to beat
jimmy connors
that's when some of the younger people
in the audience don't remember but our
tennis rackets were wooden
and she
showed poor sportsmanship on the tennis
court
and her father took her wooden racket
and cut it in two with an electric saw
so her father showed her tough love
nancy lopez was another
um i really wanted to get nancy lopez
not only do i love golf but i've always
admired her because she had to break the
glass ceiling a woman in a
male-dominated field but of course she's
mexican-american also so she had
two um
two hurdles in her career
and her father very unselfishly would
drive her to
a
golf course that would allow women to
actually play golf she never even
thought about the sacrifice that he was
made making until she later grew up and
he went with her on the circuit and
and
he would challenge her
as would many of these fathers in the
book
they weren't
you know they didn't give their
daughters everything they would
challenge their daughters and
and really encourage them i have one
woman the first
woman of an african country
the country of liberia she is dr ellen
sirleaf johnson
and her father was an indigenous tribe
member in liberia and she he was in the
legislature there
and she later became the first woman of
any african country and so i was really
proud to get her
so um
i'd love for you to read it and email me
and tell me your favorite story because
i'm doing that i'm i'm keeping a little
tally of
my husband does have a favorite story
that he would like to share with you
right now mary higgins clark
i know we got to wrap up we got to go
sign signatures
mary higgins clark turn to a page okay
39 this goes back to your question i
have no daughters so the pressure is on
you
but the mary higgins clark
and then i know again we need to wrap up
let's read it you read it okay we've
never done this but i'll do the first
paragraph you do a paragraph because
this i think it captures so much in the
book
mary higgins clark
um
she sold 80 million copies of her books
but what you see here uh is the best it
was 11 i was 11 years old when my father
died in his sleep
of a heart attack and all these decades
later never a day goes by that i don't
think of him you read
on cape cod the early settlers came
called it tortions
that special bond which exists between a
father and a daughter my father luke
joseph higgins was born in roscommon
ireland and came to the united states in
1905 when he was 21.
i have the the record of his arrival on
ellis island that states he had five
pounds in his pocket
ten years later he became an american
citizen
in those days he had to swear that he
was neither
an anarchist nor a polygamist and that
he renounced his loyalty to george 5
king of england the time i had with him
was all too limited
looking back i'm glad that i had severe
childhood asthma and frequently miss
school when the attacks came i spent a
good part of the night wheezing and
gasping for breath
but in the morning the asthma eased off
and i'd go downstairs to share brunch
with him he owned a bar and grill that
meant that he slept late in the morning
came home for an early dinner with the
family and then drove back to the place
until three in the morning the only
evening in my life that i remember him
being at home was just before he died he
had left work early because he didn't
feel well
a certain scent still reminds me of his
shaving lotion phrases of songs he sang
to me
off-key if my aunt agnes has was to be
believed still run through my mind
sunday night is my delight that's all i
can remember the rest of the words are
gone a memory of his physical appearance
remains vivid he was a man just under
six feet tall with thinning hair and a
strong face he had a quiet voice
tis dear
was the way he answered my questions in
the affirmative
like the brother and sister who came to
the united states within a year or two
of him he did not have a brogue just a
few expressions and a lilt in his voice
that was the gift of his irish ancestry
years ago i met an elderly cousin who
was the son of my father's oldest sister
i i
looked like luke
when i was growing up he explained and
as your granddad got older he would call
me luke
your dad was his favorite
i remember standing in the backyard with
him shortly before he died
as he pointed to a derivable floating
overhead
it was the hindenburg
and my father explained that it was the
new way people would travel long
distances it exploded minutes later
in one of the most famous disasters of
the 20th century
i still remember standing beside him in
the feeling of protection
i had from his presence as we looked at
the giant object floating above us
after he died i had a heart hunger for
that feeling that never abated
my mother and father were married 14
years when daddy died
joseph was 13 and i was 11 and john was
seven
years later that sad history repeated
itself my husband warren died of a heart
attack after we had been married only 14
years
our five children ranged in age from
five to thirteen
understood everything they would be
missing without their father because i
had been there
41 years later their memory of him is as
fresh as mine is as my dad a father
always wanted to go back to ireland for
a visit
but never made it
there was never that much time to get
away from the bar and grill
25 years after his death i visited
ireland
for the very first time the house where
he had been raised is gone but the barn
with its old oak door was still there
my father had told me how he and his
brothers and sisters had carved their
name into that door
i found his name luke
and i ran my finger over it
at that moment i felt as though i had
not made that visit for him
but with him
i looked over those beautiful green
hills and i and whispered it's lovely
here daddy
last line
i felt as though i was hearing him
whisper back tis dear
so that's bill's favor that's great
and i will say on that note i did have
love you daddy
kleenexes made because it's really hard
to get through some of these chapters
and we return now to the chicago tribune
printer zero book fair up next stephen
harper talks about his book crossing
hoffa dealing with his own father's
efforts to clean up corruption in the
teamsters union
welcome to the 23rd annual chicago
tribune printers row book fair we're
pleased to provide a forum where book
lovers and authors can come together and
exchange ideas and thoughts
we would like to give a special thanks
to our sponsors and community partners
who helped make this event possible and
just a few housekeeping notes before we
begin today's session
our event is being broadcast live for
book tv on cspan2
and out of courtesy to our authors and
panelists and all of our guests could
you please turn off your cell phone and
all other electronic devices flash
photography is also not permitted
and now i'll turn things over to our
moderator jim grossman
vice president for research and
education at the newberry library thank
you
[Applause]
good afternoon uh first i'd like to
reiterate the uh cell phone advice
uh i've been doing these for three or
four years now and there's always
somebody who's forgotten uh this year
it's probably me so
uh
it is a great pleasure for me to both
introduce and to interview stephen
harper
and i think uh having having grown up
with johnny carson and the tonight show
i'll do the
uh holding up the book which i learned
oh
here's the real one
crossing teamster
crossing hoffa a teamster story is the
book that's on the table today
and
steve harper is a litigation partner at
kirkland and ellis where he's been for i
think 28 years is that correct
he's a graduate of northwestern
university and harvard law school
he is listed in the best lawyers in
america and illinois super lawyers so
those of you who have any problems that
you need taken care of can catch him
afterwards
this is his first book
and in what i think is an unusual way of
conducting your life especially when you
have a full-time job as a lawyer he has
a second book which will be coming out
very very soon so obviously he's been
working on both of these at the same
time
which will be published by northwestern
university press and is tentatively
titled straddling worlds the jewish
american journey of professor richard w
leopold leopold was a historian who
taught at northwestern who passed away
recently
it's very hard to write two books in a
row uh at the same time
it's very hard to write one book and so
to do two at the same time in some ways
i think is like learning two languages
at the same time it's easy to get one
story confused with the other and
whatnot
this book crossing hoffa a teamsters
story
is
is interesting on many different levels
and
i thought about starting off by talking
about the book by summarizing the book
but i think actually it's better for
steve to do that uh what's interesting
about the book or one of the things is
that it's a combination
it's a personal memoir
it's a biography but a certain kind of
biography because it's a biography of
steve's father
and it's also a historical work
those of us who have read a fair amount
in labor history can learn a lot from
this book
there are what a dozen biographies of
jimmy hoffa out there
and i haven't read them all
i actually do know somebody who's read
them all so now i know two people who
have read them all
i've read a few of them
and it's hard to say something new about
jimmy hoffa unless you know where he's
buried
so
what i'd like to do is to start off with
the aspect of this
that is the most personal if i can and
then we'll get the book out gradually
the book is about yourself and your
father
yes um and thank you for your kind
remarks you you read them just as my
mother wrote them
i'm good at that let me let me give you
a synopsis maybe just so everyone has a
sense of what the book's about it's the
story of my father's two-year tango with
jimmy hoffa from 1959 to 1961.
he was an over-the-road truck driver a
loyal teamster
and he thought that he could help
hoffa improve the union because that was
what hoffa wanted that's what he said he
wanted
and the way he thought he would do that
was by
going after what he thought was a
corrupt leader of the local in
minneapolis
what he didn't realize was that he and
what he would never realize in many ways
was the he had inadvertently crossed
swords with jimmy hoffa himself
because hoffa
had in fact selected
the leader
of the local that my father had targeted
the insurgency succeeded
for several months in fact it succeeded
so well that it got onto hoffa's radar
screen
which of course doomed it
hoffa came to town minneapolis met with
my father and three others privately for
three and a half hours in a downtown
minneapolis hotel room
told my father to stop
my father refused and for the next 18
months found himself on the receiving
end of death threats and murder attempts
attempts all of which he survived
and so the story
my mission after my father died 40 years
later
when i discovered the artifacts of what
he always referred to as his union fight
was to try to discern the answer to two
questions and as jim suggests one is a
is a memoir it's a personal question
what was it that motivated my father
to continue to proceed with this
really hopeless crusade
after hoffa himself had personally told
him to stop
and then the second thing that drove my
my question was
why would hoffa care what what is it
about minneapolis that would draw the
attention of the world's most powerful
and charismatic
labor leader at that time so and the
book what really i think grabs one about
this book at the beginning is that
personal story
uh
the books start the first as on many
books the first book starts on page
three so page seven is pretty soon
when you get to the bottom of page seven
you're barely into this book
and you get a story that practically
made me jump out of my chair and
actually as i was sitting there in my
living room reading this i started
doing one of the awful
awful obnoxious things that you do where
you're reading a book and you can't
resist looking up and telling your
family listen listen to this so this is
where i first did this my wife had to
sit through that as i wrote it
numerous times i suspect
uh
and here steve is talking about when
he's six years
old i remember the fervor with which he
told me never to accept a ride from
anyone
ever
someone might even tell you that mom and
i have been hurt
and that you should get in the car to
see us at the hospital
that won't be true
only mom or i will ever come to get you
if for some reason neither of us can the
only person we would send is grandpa
no one else
if anyone else tries run away
and scream as loud as you can
steve's next line is something that i
think any parent might have written next
is this was not your typical stranger
danger discussion with a six-year-old
child
how do you get
to that point
how do you get to the point of of that
conversation
well at by that time
the first phase what i would call the
first phase of my dad's struggle had
been lost hoff had come to town and told
him to stop
but my dad had not stopped and we can
talk about some of the reasons for that
and so
what was happening at that time
were death threats that were coming into
our house typically while my mother was
home alone with her four kids
uh i was the oldest six
um
and um my younger brother was one and
there were two two sisters in between
when they'd go something like this
hi mary i hope things are okay for jim
on the road you know a lot of bad things
can happen to a person on the road
click uh this particular discussion that
jim refers to came about because what my
father decided to do after a series of
those kinds of things
was set up very elaborate and very
secret
uh tape recording devices in our home
and this is 1960 so you don't have
anything like the technology that you
have now
and
he set up the the machinery and one day
while he was home
a call came in and he answered the phone
and the call was along the lines of the
following
hi jim
i hope everything's all right with your
kids
happen to notice your son walking home
from school the other day you know a
father is awfully important to a young
boy i sure hope everything's okay
click
this conversation the stranger danger
discussion followed that call why
why would they go to such lengths uh i
mean
your father was a loyal teamster
this is not we're just talking about
this is not this book is not a critique
of the teamsters union in fact it's uh
in in some ways one
puts this book down realizing how
important the union was to truckers uh
and how useful it was
uh
your father was one of thousands of of
ordinary truck drivers uh many of whom
perhaps might have questioned the
leadership in their union uh
hoffa had all sorts of things to be
worrying about at this time so why is he
worried about your father you you've hit
upon what was really the second central
question that drove my my inquiry which
was why did hoffa care
what was happening in minneapolis and
the answer is and my father would never
know this even 40 years later when he
died he wouldn't know this
until i discovered it
but the answer is that it turned out
that some of the very difficulties legal
difficulties that were
destined to put hoffa in prison
four years after all of this was
happening in my family
were incubating and developing in
minneapolis
people and events in that city were at
the heart
of the activities relating to the
central state pension fund fraud
for which hoffa would eventually be
convicted of of fraud
by a chicago jury in 1964. people tend
to think of jimmy hoffa as having been
convicted of wiretapping i'm sorry of
of
jury tampering which he was
that's that's sort of the most sort of
rhetorically interesting way to describe
what happened to him but a month later
he was convicted in chicago
for pension fraud and
both he served a seven-year term or was
sentenced to serve a senior seven-year
term concurrently with both and
minneapolis was the center of the action
so the last thing that hoffa needed
in 1960 61 and 62 was
anything happening in minneapolis and my
father was generating media attention in
the city what was he doing
well what he had done initially was
launch an insurgency when it failed the
first time he what he was doing the
second in the second round and that's
the reason he had the electronic
equipment
was he was amassing a case that he
thought would be irrefutable the he was
he was going to get tape recordings of
the the person who he had targeted as
the corrupt local leader in his view
he would get that person to admit that
what he was doing was wrong he would
then present all that to hoffa
in a way that would make it impossible
for hoffa to
ignore
and then in that way clean up the union
but the problem was hoffa's interests at
that point were
in keeping control over every aspect of
the union because he was already in a
world where he was under government
supervision the court had ordered
uh government supervision of the
teamsters union back in 1957 and hoffa
was just trying to keep everything under
control so that he could have a new
election and he would get out from under
the the government supervision but your
father had no sense of
of hoffa himself
as a corrupt man that's my understanding
from the book for most of the period
covered in this book in fact he saw
hoffa as a hero and a victim well that's
exactly right and it's easy looking back
through the prism of history to view
hoffa much differently from the way
people viewed him in 1960 but at that
point he had already been tried and
acquitted that is found not guilty
in trial after trial after trial so that
as far as my father was concerned this
whole effort of trying to
convict hoffa things and people accusing
him of all these bad things
was simply part of a lot much larger
federal government labor busting union
busting agenda so he was it was very
easy for him to just see uh hoffa is
really the savior of the union which is
the way
um
i think most of the rank and file viewed
him so he did not
he did not and i think only with great
reluctance would he ever associate
anything bad that was happening to him
to hoffa personally so
why did your father do this i mean this
this local had 3 000 members
and
there were hundreds of other locals
across the country whose
uh secretary treasurer business agent
president trustees were all equally cr
as corrupt if not more corrupt than
fritz snyder was
why your father
what was it the kind of man he was was
it the situation well my father couldn't
talk about what was happening in any any
local other than his own and as luck
would have it he was stuck in what
turned out to be a very historically
significant local 544 in minneapolis and
what my father came to the local with
was a personal past
that had really put him in search of an
episode or an event or something that
would allow him to redeem what had been
a very troubled life
and i mean what i mean troubled life i
mean
13 months in in what had been
in 1952 51-52
described by collier's magazine as
america's worst prison
in angola louisiana so he was on a track
to try to
repair
and ultimately redeem his life and so
ferreting out finding somebody tipped
him
somebody in the uh
who
presumably knew had tipped him you know
if you go after this guy there's there's
glory to be had
and i think my father viewed this as a
as a defining opportunity for for
redemption in his life and i think
that's why he proceeded as he did and he
thought and he thought hoffa would
reward him he really did believe that
because you know that's what hoffa was
about that was his rhetoric and and he
really thought hoffa would reward him
and what did it take for him to lose
that faith
um
well i guess ultimately you could say it
took him
the loss of his
job
and his and our home
and
and in a funny way i'm not even sure
that did it
um
because even even notwithstanding
all the other things that all of the
things that happened i'm not sure my
father
ever thought that
that there was anything
um that he would say well this is this
is somehow hoffa's fault what happened
to me you know my father was more along
was more would have been more inclined
to view a situation like this by saying
you know i should have gone about this
in a different way if i just kind of
bought it in a different way i could and
i could have made it would have
convinced me to could have done that
that was the mission that was so even
even in that i think it was very would
have been very hard for him to say i
can't blame any from anyone else for
for what happened here but that was sort
of the person he was well in that sense
again as one reads the book you
you have a real sense that your father
father has a relationship with hafa even
though they only meet once i believe
that's correct
and
the book looking at that relation is
much about that relationship even though
it's a one-sided view of it in many ways
through that relationship do you think
that you have a different sense of jimmy
hoffa a sense of huff that's different
from
the dozen biographers who have read more
of hoffas through more of hoffa's
material than you have who have read
more of the historical sources but is
there a way that you have a different
insight i have i guess two reactions uh
two thoughts and one is the the first
insight i had that was absolutely
remarkable to me and would have stunned
my father if he could see it now
is the pervasive connection that his
hometown of minneapolis and the local
had not only do to to his particular
episode but to jimmy hoffa jimmy hoffa's
beginning
in the national spotlight as a union
later started in minneapolis and it and
ultimately the events as i'd said as i
described that led to his imprisonment
uh were swirling in minneapolis so
there's a minnesota's theme to this that
would have just stunned my father but
beyond that i think there was a
what i thought sort of came away with i
guess is this notion that sometimes you
can look at at small events like this
and you can real reveal
or see
ways that people operate
that
give insight into them for example
people think of jimmy hoffa as being
this this sort of person who pounds the
table and and gets in people's faces and
is just tough as nails and he was
there's no question about that he's
jimmy hoffa is not somebody who ever
wanted mad at you
um
but he described him in here as or your
father described him as a man who was
certainly not small and did not have an
ounce of fat he was five foot five um
and you you you didn't want to mess with
him you know he you just didn't want to
mess with him
but but
although you had he had that capacity i
this is and this is just my sort of
coming away with the thing he had the
capacity to be sort of in your face
he also had
a very sly ability i think
to put in motion behind the scenes
people and places and and events in in a
minute in a manipulative kind of way so
that by indirection he could accomplish
um what he might not want to be
associated with directly uh in terms of
certain things that he wanted happen for
example you will i don't think you will
ever find
anything that says well
um
jimmy hoffa to say somebody's saying
cut jim harper's break lines you won't
find that it didn't happen
in that way that's not the way those
sorts of episodes happen but on the
other hand if you know jimmy hoffa and
you know the way he ran the union in
those years you also knew
that
things things of a very dramatic nature
that would have far-reaching influence
just didn't happen unless he was at a
minimum acquiescing in them well and
this would have been the definition in
some ways of an effective lieutenant
would have been somebody who knew what
he wanted didn't have to ask him to do
it
uh and would have it done without him
ever knowing excellent point that's an
excellent point right it's the most
loyal and most capable right assistant
and you describe two of those people in
here actually quite graphically uh
steinberg and i forget the other one
from new york
uh who actually exactly canola
yes who act exactly in that in that
manner sure
so that one of the ways that they tried
to stop the insurgency in the first wave
for example was
uh hoffa had this fella steinberg who
was his right-hand personal assistant
and he showed up at a business meeting
and he basically announces to everyone
that he's here to communicate so
everyone knows
alpha wants this to end
well and there's a certain ethos in a
way that runs through the book that
teamsters share
i think that have to do with standing up
to people with with manliness i'm
curious how many people here have ever
driven a truck
okay not yeah not very many uh
driving a truck is a very important
theme in this book it's not just that
your father drove a truck and he was a
teamster
driving a truck has much to do with your
father's sense as a man i sense in in
this and in fact
that sense of failure that runs through
his early life which partly lands him in
angola and is partly a result of that is
he redeems himself through driving a
truck right that's how he finds himself
as a self yes and
hoffa never drove a truck correct never
drove a chop everyone assumes jimmy
hoffa must have been over the
uh road driver never drove a truck
and the reaction to the audience is sort
of confirmation of somebody i wish i
could remember who said it that there's
really no new history so you just have
to keep repeating the old history that
already exists so that new people hear
it
but that's uh he was never he never
drove a truck but he was the most
effective recruiter of over-the-road
drivers
probably in the history of the teamsters
because he identified with them he he
you know he could
they were his guy did your father know
that hoffa never drove a truck
i don't know the answer to that would
have mattered
i don't think so i think he would have
said
my father i think would have formed his
opinion about somebody based upon his
reaction to that person
and i think that whether or not he drove
a truck would not have probably made a
difference i don't think to his
assessment of having met him personally
and seen him you know that way in action
right okay i know you know i get it when
you were doing the research for this
book i was thinking about this we were
talking about the surprise uh
people
about hoffa never driving a truck when
you were doing the research what
surprised you
either about
your father or also about the historical
issues here
well the biggest surprise i think came
to me when
i found out that a newspaper reporter
for the minneapolis star tribune
in whom my father had confided
off the record to sort of let him know
what was happening in the early days of
the insurgency and that resulted in some
newspaper coverage
i was astonished to learn that that
newspaper man
after he died in about only three or
four years after this all happened
someone had donated to the minnesota
historical society press
several boxes of his private papers
and among them
were
correspondence
between him and the teamsters leadership
during this time and what my father
never knew
was that this reporter for the the
minneapolis star tribune um who he
thought was his friend
he was leaking materials to him
he was telling him everything right yep
and so it would make the newspapers
he was actually
at the exact same time that all this
story was unfolding for my father
he was writing a book
and he was writing a book about the
teamsters
and in order to be able to write the
book about the teamsters
hoffa had given him
the highest access to the highest levels
of the teamster leadership that no one
else ever got
um
and so as a result and and he was
uh there's no question about it when you
read the correspondence from this
reporter you can't miss it he was an
uh absolute hoffa loyalist although the
stuff that you quote in here is it's
groveling practically i mean the fulsome
correspondence well it raises sort of
this interesting question that is
obviously timeless which is what is a
newspaper man's relationship to his
sources and how does all that play out
and at what point are you so reliant on
your sources that you can't really
look at them with a with this
with a kind of scrutiny that we all
think
uh journalists and reporters are
supposed to do and i you know i think we
all think there's a contemporary
application to some of those issues well
and it wasn't just journal him as a
journalist he also what's interesting to
me as a historian is that he was writing
in as part of a scholarly series being
published by the university of
california right through i assume their
labor relations institute
one of my undergraduate teachers in fact
was involved in this project i came
across his name in there so there was
also that
sort of uh veneer of scholarship yes of
disinterested scholarship in what he was
doing yes uh the whole time that he was
feeding your father's right private
information and if you now go back and
read that book which i did um and look
at it with
with with the perspective that i have on
what else was happening during that
period
you have some you have some interesting
reactions to some of the ways that the
reporter in the book describes hoffa
and some of the things that were going
on well i wonder if that's actually
the answer to the other question that
was i was wondering about as i was
reading the book but maybe it's a
different episode that is when i read
this book i kept thinking if i was
writing this book about my father
i'd be getting really angry at certain
points as i'm doing this work
were there parts were there points
well that was my question to you
uh were there points where you just got
angry
where you got upset where there was
someone who that's you just put down
your your computer as you were taking
your notes and you just were too ticked
off to continue for a few minutes
well
this may be a personality defect that i
have
but
when i go back and look at things with
with a distance of 40 years
i don't really make room for upset
i do i do have lots of room for surprise
shock
you can sort of i guess at a level you
can feel badly about some of the things
that are happening but you already know
the story so you know how it comes out
and you also know that in the end it
actually comes out
you know and there's a sense in which
this story is about how you can struggle
and and lose and actually not lose you
win in ways you don't realize that you
win and so forth so that
knowing as i did
all along how it would come out it it
sort of i guess it squelched any impulse
that which wasn't very great that i
might have had for upset
we could go on and on because there's
lots in this book that's absolutely
fascinating but it is important that we
give you a chance to ask questions uh
i am curious
uh have any of you
who are here uh been members of the
international brotherhood of teamsters
i've changed once upon a time uh anyway
if you have questions please go up to
use the microphone
we are going to be broadcast on c-span i
am told
and hence uh it will be more effective
in broadcast terms if you ask your
questions from the microphone so
yes
well
sherman sconic
on his newswire reported that
it was nixon and fitzgerald who had
hoffa killed
or did that turn up in your research
my uh let me tell you what i the best
the best answer i've heard to the
question of
what happened to jimmy hoffa
i think is provided by a book that
charles brandt wrote an excellent book
about two years ago called i heard you
paint houses
and
his
his book is is a book about
what there are lots of theories about
what happened to hoffa
uh i think brandt's book is the one that
lays out in the most persuasive way
because he
tells the story of one of his former
clients who claims on his deathbed
claimed on his deathbed
that he was the one who
who killed hoffa
after he disappeared from a parking lot
outside detroit
so who was he who who was the person who
did it yes who says he did it who says
he did it who says he did it right um
uh frank shiran is the person the the
name of the book is i heard you paint
houses
uh motive
pardon me did frank shirad have a motive
well frank shiran says that he was part
of organized criminal activity that was
ultimately
ultimately directed
that that's what happened to office at
the time hoffa disappeared
he was
trying to get
back into the leadership of the union
he'd been out of prison
richard nixon had pardoned him people
forget that
it turned out actually that richard
nixon and jimmy hoffa's relationship
actually began and it's covered in in
the in the period of the story that my
dad was doing all this stuff 1959 that's
when that relationship began
um nixon uh released hoffa from from uh
prison but there was a restriction that
was very controversial and the
restriction was that hoffa could not
return to union leadership for a number
of years
so hofu was in the process of
challenging that restriction in court
when he disappeared
and he was also in the process of
preparing to run
and replace
the then president of the teamsters
frank spitz simmons so the speculation
is and and no one will ever know i
suspect the true answer but as i say
brant's book i think it's the closest
uh the speculation is that for a variety
of reasons
people just did not want hoffa back in
running the teamsters one of the one of
the theories is he had made it clear
that he was going to
eliminate the organized criminal element
in the teamsters or at least that's what
he said he was going to try to do so
there is speculation that there were
people who didn't want him back well
maybe it was spit simmons rather than
fit
right have been wrong
and this is one of the i think this
question highlights in some ways one of
the fascinating and what i think is
valuable things about this book which is
that
the book returns us to thinking about
hoffa as a unionist and as a union
leader
and now whenever hoffa's name comes up
instead what what emerges immediately
from the conversation is whether his
body is underneath the meadowlands
and we one of the nice things about the
perennial book fair is that they ask
panelists to show up early and they
actually feed us and give us something
to drink and we sit around at tables and
chat with each other and we were just
chatting about hoffa and the gentleman
who was sitting at the table with us who
i didn't you didn't neither of us had
ever met he looks up and he says oh i
was just talking to someone who knows
where jimmy hoffa is
and
so this is you mention hoffa and that's
the first thing that pops up and so one
of the things that this book does is it
does return him into that milieu of the
union yeah rather than the question of
who killed jimmy hoffa right right
sherman scotland said atf killed him and
sherman scolnick called up the atf and
told him where hoffer was buried
under uh in in michigan on the barn they
dug up a barn last summer yeah uh yeah
and then they they went and dug him up
and re-buried him in new jersey
according to the stolen right that's the
that's the meadowlands story
what the medal is in new jersey right
underneath the giants stadium is the
yeah so supposedly they play football
over jimmy hoffa's body i can only share
with you and my father had no inside
information on this at all but in 1975
when the news report broke that he had
disappeared and no one knew where he was
my father turned to me and said
they'll never find him again
and i think that's probably right but
who knows thank you next
the good news for me is that because the
book is called crossing off it'll do
much better than if i'd called it
crossing george
or the the union leader who he did
really cross was fred snyder and right
crossing snyder was yeah whatever anyway
that's not going to do it
did the politics and the team street
union have anything to do with the
politics and the farmers farmer labor
party because i know that they had
thrown out some unions about 15 years
before for being too left-wing were they
in any way related or was this
completely out of
i don't know the answer your question
for sure in terms of my father's
struggle or if you take it back back to
the 30s and 40s
one of the reasons that that minneapolis
was such a historically significant
local that i never knew about is that it
was a
it had been run by trotskyites
and uh the one the reason and the way
that
jimmy hoffa first emerged as a national
political national leader of the
teamsters was when the then president of
the teamsters sent off a to minneapolis
because he was concerned
that in the in the very very successful
recruiting efforts that the trotskyite
local was doing in minneapolis
that he couldn't the the you
he wanted hoffman
to basically kill all you know squelch
all that because he wanted to the
president the then president of
teamsters wanted to maintain control of
the union in minneapolis was looked like
it was kind of going off on its own and
to the left and hoffa got his claim to
fame because early claim to fame when he
was very young in minneapolis because he
squelched all that and
the leader of the local had wound up
being among the first
incarcerations under the civil
incarcerations under the smith act of
1940. well one of the reasons why that's
an interesting question that you've
posed is something that i think is is
happening in the background of this book
which is cold war domestic politics that
part of what you described
does have to do with the dfl
dealing with the pressures of the cold
war and anti-communism
and what nixon and hoffa have in common
is hostility to the left hostility to
communists
and hoffa part of hafa's rise does have
to do with
the fact that he is more acceptable to
some american politicians because he
won't tolerate any left influence yeah
although most of the the most important
thing that hoffa and nixon had in common
was that they hated the kennedys that's
right uh you know people forget but it
was it was bobby kennedy in 1957 who
first started going after hoffa in a
very big way and after he became
attorney general in 1960 he set up what
they called a get office squad
um i mean the truth of the matter is if
you really
put in context what was happening at the
time you do come away with this view
that boy this really does look like if
you were looking at it in 1960 or 61
this really does look like everybody is
out to get this guy i mean it re the
resources that were devoted and the
attention that he got were pretty
remarkable and in the context of the
times that you can see how it would be
viewed as really class warfare in a very
real way
between the haves and the have-nots and
that was sort of the backdrop against
which my father
proceeded and it was also one of the
things that i think made him reluctant
to view hoffa as in some ways anything
but heroic this actually this moves a
little bit off the focus of your book
but surely you came across this in your
reading
do we know much about
why bobby kennedy
went after half of the way why hoffa
you know there's a there's a story and i
don't know if it's true because bobby
kennedy denied it
and uh but hoffa said it was true in his
autobiography and the story is that
initially it started as
and actually the book details how all of
the the government hearings into labor
corruption began they they they too
actually began in minneapolis i mean
that's minneapolis keeps coming back as
a central
sort of recurring nightmare or theme of
the story depending on your point of
view
but at some point there was a crossover
from
inves investigation to vendetta
somewhere in the process
and i think it occurred very early on
because kennedy when kennedy bobby
kennedy came on as the council to the
senate committee that was investigating
the teamsters because there was a
continuity of investigation into the
teamsters what changed was who the
particular people were
who were investigating over time but
there was a
story that hoffa told that very early on
when hoffa was first going to appear
in uh
or in in the hearings
that he and bobby kennedy had a private
dinner
at
it had been arranged by office lawyer at
hoffa's lawyer's home
and
according to hoffa and again i have no
you know who knows
he challenged bobby kennedy to an arm
wrestling match
and of course bobby ken you know the
kennedys we all know they're all strong
and virile
and this five foot five guy uh
well off of you know was one of these
done you know and and uh want to go
again and obviously no no i'm good i'm
in the phone and then the phone rang and
it was supposedly ethel with a problem
with a with a kid and hoffa believes
that he could believed that he could
trace the origins to the blood feud
to the fact that he didn't let bobby
kennedy win that arm wrestling match in
his lawyer's home well this is i mean
it's interesting because this is as i
said earlier this is a theme that does
run through this book which is manliness
yes
oh yes it is on virtually every page
and the
fellow who really becomes your father's
best friend closest confidant marvin
masteller right is in some way
he even describes a truck in gendered
terms that you master the truck
uh the way a man masters another man and
an army you arm wrestle that truck to
the ground damn it
that's how your father describes almost
dying was arm wrestling that truck to
the ground wasn't it yes yes that's
exactly right um
yeah i guess everything is a metaphor
for everything else but
uh no that's exactly right and and
masteller is a figure
um
my mother still remembers him he's
if you've met masteller you've you never
forget him um
and and he i think is he emerges as a as
an interesting character in the book
and and all of these fellas and the
other thing that's very interesting um
and i don't know how others react to it
but if i've talked to a number of of
teamsters
older teamsters
in the course of doing this
there is this there's a continuing
abiding loyalty to hoffa that is
absolutely there and you can understand
it because at the time that hoffa ran
the union he was adding a thousand new
members a week to the membership roles a
thousand members a week
that hasn't happened since i mean the
teamsters union is about the same size
that it was when hoffa was last running
it and so you know he was a he was a
magical mythical people which is why i'm
glad you made the point too which is
people do tend to lose sight of
the larger hoffa you know the people who
have this this gut reaction that has to
do with well where is he and you know
there was a joke you probably all saw it
on the last one a recent episode on the
sopranos for those of you who watch it
where tony soprano is being operated on
in the surgeon who's otherwise very dead
deadpan
cuts them open and says
oh my god and the nurse turns to the
surgeon and says what is it doctor
he said tony soprano's a gigantic guy as
you all know
i just found jimmy hoffa
and on that we are going to end uh i
want to thank everybody for coming uh
the printer's row book fair wants to
thank you all for coming it's a
beautiful day outside there's a lot of
books to look at
so please be my guest thank you
thank you
thank you for attending today's
discussion and for supporting the
chicago tribune's commitment to literacy
feel free to stay here for our next
guest or enjoy our programming at other
venues
stephen harper will now sign books in
the park room which is the first room on
your left as you exit this room if you
need to purchase a copy they are
available through the barnes noble
station here on the second floor thank
you
[Music]
coverage of the chicago tribune
printer's row book fair and author
stephen harper on his book crossing
hoffa
up next robert dalek on nixon and
kissinger his latest book on their
difficult partnership in running
american foreign policy and we'll bring
you a discussion with jan crawford
greenberg who wrote supreme conflict and
jeffrey stone author of war and liberty
and the final author of the day will be
ken alder to talk about his book the lie
detectors
this is coverage of the chicago tribune
printers row book fair on book tv
lorraine schuyler is the author of the
weight of their vote jason deparle
good evening and thank you all for
coming to politics and pros my name is
alan watki i'm a book seller here where
we host close to a thousand authors a
year
for a full list of everything that is
confirmed for the rest of the year
please go to our website
politicspros.com or you can pick up one
of our monthly event calendars uh
throughout the store with the current
listing go going through the end of
october
before we get started today i'd like to
ask you to please silence your cell
phones so as not to disrupt the event
and when it's time for the q a i'd ask
you to please step up to the mic
so we can hear your question as we are
audio recording it and c-span is
recording for book tv
following the q a we'll have a signing
right up here at this table so if you
haven't already purchased the book we
have plenty of them right up front at
the registers
and then if you could fold up your
chairs and lean them against something
solid that would be a great help thank
you
so without further ado tonight i'm very
excited to welcome jack goldsmith to
politics and pros
uh celebrating his newest work in
hafez's shadow
a stepfather a disappearance in detroit
and my search for the truth
there have been many theories about the
fate of jimmy hoffa long-time president
of the international brotherhood of
teamsters since he disappeared in 75.
many involved charles chucky o'brien
a hoffa's aide and goldsmith's
stepfather in the compelling account
goldsmith recounts how his childhood
affection for o'brien
became more complicated as he pursued a
legal career
then when the perspective he gained for
serving as assistant attorney general
under george w bush goldsmith was moved
to uncover the truth about o'brien
hoffa the mob the waning labor labor's
power and the rise of the surveillance
state
in hoffa's shadow tells the moving story
of how goldsmith reunited with the
stepfather he disowned and then set out
to unravel one of the 20th century's
most
persistent mysteries and chucky's role
in it
goldsmith is the henrielle shattuck
professor at harvard law school a senior
fellow at the hoover institutes
institute
headed the office of legal counsel
in the george w bush administration
which during his tenure he challenged
the warrantless wiretapping program and
withdrew two memos written before his
tenure justifying the use of torture in
the war against terrorism he has also
authored terror presidency as well as
power and constraint so please join me
in welcoming to politics and pros jack
goldsmith
[Applause]
so thank you thank you very much to
politics and pros for hosting this event
thanks to you all for coming out tonight
even though there's serious competition
with the democratic debate and
a certain baseball team that i know
there are many fans for i'm grateful
that you came
so my tale begins in june of 1975 when i
was 12 years old
i was living in west memphis arkansas
and
my mother in june of 1975 married what
was her third husband uh his name was
charles chuckie o'brien
uh i did not have a my birth father was
not a terribly good father my stepfather
the second marriage was not a great
father so i hadn't really had a great
father figure in my life by the time i
was 12 years old
and chucky o'brien shows up on the scene
and he they got married in june of 75
and i had known him for about six months
before then
and i immediately glommed on to him and
he was an amazing father
he showed me the love and affection i
never had we did everything together and
i thought he was the greatest
12 years old six months after my mom
married him jimmy hoffa disappeared
mysteriously from a parking lot in um
in the suburbs of detroit michigan in
bloomfield hills outside of a restaurant
that was then called the marcus red fox
to this day
there's no direct evidence of what
happened to hoffa he vanished
there are lots of theories but no one
knows what happens what happened
he was in the parking lot he was seen in
the parking lot as late as 2 45 and the
next thing we know he had his last phone
call at 3 30
and that's it
there are lots of theories about how he
was picked up
but we don't know to this day what
happened to hoffa now who is jimmy hoffa
jimmy hoffa as many people in the room
may know
was in the 50s and 60s one of the most
well-known public figures in the country
he led the teamsters union which was the
most powerful union in the country at a
time when unions mattered
he was had an outsized personality he
was an extraordinary
labor leader for the teamsters and he
was also corrupt in many ways he had
many ties to organize crime he cut side
deals all the time he used the pension
fund to line his own pockets
but he was this huge large figure and
he
basically went to jail in 1967 for a
variety of things he was out of jail in
71
when richard nixon pardoned him or
commuted his sentence i should say
and he was trying to regain the
presidency of the teamsters when he was
disappeared
probably almost certainly at the behest
of the mob
because basically hoffa was trying to
win back the teamsters union the
presidency of the teamsters union the
mob had taken over control of the
teamsters union much more than when he
was president and they didn't want him
back they feared he was going to spill
all their secrets about because he was
threatening to do so
and
there's pretty good evidence
circumstance on otherwise that it was
mob organized there's a lot of evidence
of that but no evidence of what happened
that day
one week after the disappearance chucky
o'brien became the lead suspect
chucky o'brien was also hoffa's
right-hand man
from the early 50s basically until he
disappeared until the year before he
disappeared he met hoffa when he was
nine years old and he was by hoffa's
side basically all the time from the
early 50s
until he went to prison and then after
prison until just before he disappeared
many people thought that chucky was
hoffa's illegitimate son because they
were so close
and they were just extremely close they
were always together
and so it was quite an extraordinary
thing when six days after the
disappearance my stepfather became the
leading suspect now for those of you who
remember
it was a circus the hoffa disappearance
was a circus
it was front page news every day it was
on the evening news every night for
weeks
and it was just an incredible maelstrom
and i was in the middle of it because i
was this 12 year old kid who's that new
stepdad who he revered as the leading
suspect
so during the next five years during my
high school years the formative years of
my life as i look back on it chucky was
caught up and he why was he the leading
suspect to be to be brief there was a
lot of circumstantial evidence that
pointed towards him being involved
including that he was in the vicinity at
the time of the disappearance he had had
a break with hoffa six or eight months
earlier he was driving a car uh that was
the car of the son of the leading
detroit mobster who was thought to have
organized the hit
hoffa's hair was a hair matching hoffa
was later found in the car and half a
cent was found in the car
so there were circumstantial evidence
pointing to it towards him the fbi had
every reason to focus in on him
so the next five years of my life was
basically
there were two or three things going on
one chucky and i became like this
i came to revere him as i said he was an
extraordinary father i came to revere
the teamsters union i came to revere
teamster's union his union identity
i came to revere
the mobsters that he was close with
you may have heard of anthony jacqueline
and anthony provinzano tony pro a new
jersey mobster those are both uncle tony
to me i spent a lot of time at their
house
i thought they were wonderful gentlemen
and i believed my stepfather when i when
he told me
that the mob really didn't exist i mean
i just kind of bought the whole thing
this is at the same time that i was
hanging out with these folks and that he
was my father and we were very close the
hoffa stuff was just out of control and
the government was all over him
and he was basically painted in the
press as the guy who did it and it's to
this day it's conventional wisdom that
chucky was the person
who drove hoffa to his death if you type
in chucky o'brien and jimmy hoffa into
google you will find that that's the
person who who did it who picked hoffa
up
so i go to college in 1980 and over the
next six or seven years i start to
rethink chucky
when i got to college i read uh books
about the hoffa disappearance for the
first time one of which was dan maldea's
great book the half of war stands in the
back there
and it turns out
this may seem naive but it turns out the
mafia did actually exist it turned out
that my uncle tony my uncles tony were
violent guys
it turned out my stepfather was had a
criminal past
all things that i kind of
either was dimly aware of or didn't
focus on when i was in high school
also i came to worry that maybe my life
would be endangered from being
from hanging out with chucky from being
his son
i came to
when i used to revel in his union
identity and i came i used to revel in
his
making fun of education my values
started changing in college and i came
to admire him less
and finally i started thinking about my
career my professional career i was
accepted at yale law school and i
started to think
maybe it won't be such a great thing to
be an attorney
especially if i have any ambitions to be
in the government which i only barely
did to have these very close mob ties
and to be the foster son or excuse me
the step son of the leading suspect in
the hoffa disappearance
so to make a very long story short um
i cut chucky out of my life and it was a
slow process about five or six years the
gradual process
and i concluded basically by the time i
finished in law school that i needed to
go on with my life and have nothing to
do with him i had convinced myself at
the time that he was a bad person
that i was a virtuous person and needed
to stay on a virtuous path
that he had either wronged me or might
wrong me
and i built all this up in my mind and i
basically cut him out of my life and it
was brutal
and it hurt him quite a lot in ways
that i didn't appreciate at the time and
i'll come back to at the end of this
talk
um so
it turned out this was a very good idea
from a professional standpoint
the year after i got out of law school i
was clerking for jay harvey wilkinson on
the fourth circuit and the first thing
he asked me to do
was to work on a case that required me
to get a classified security clearance a
secret clearance
and i filled out the forms and i as the
forms require i put down all my aliases
i pointed out that i was my name was
jack o'brien from the age of 13 to 21. i
didn't say jack o'brien comma the son of
the leading suspect in the hoffa
disappearance but i did fill out the
forms properly
about a week later um
three two or three fbi agents come to
charlottesville where i was working at
the time i thought it was this with a
standard um security clearance interview
i didn't know what they were at the time
i later found out through a privacy act
request that this set off alarm bells
inside the fbi
and they thought that you know they had
access to
someone who was close to the leading
suspect mohamed experience and they were
going to learn something
so basically uh i spent a day with the
fbi and they were basically grilled me
for a day very unexpected to me i didn't
expect this at all and i thought i was
i thought i was finished in terms of
getting a security clearance
about everything i knew about the mob
everything i knew about chucky my
attitudes towards chucky and the like
well to make a long story short i
convinced them that i didn't have mob
values and i convinced them that i had
separated myself from chucky and i got
the clearance
and that's kind of a metaphor for the
next 20 years of my career i kept
getting the clearance as i got fancier
and fancier government jobs
and i did so basically because i tossed
chucky under the bus it was as from a
career perspective
it was uh it was a good move in terms of
professional development
um
so i'm skipping over a lot of things
because i want to get to
what through the writing of this book
and what it's about it's about what i'm
telling you now is how the book opens
um
so fast forward
15 18 years later i'm working in the
justice department
i'm the assistant attorney general for
the office of legal counsel a job i
never would have had i never would have
gotten had i not done what i did to
chucky 20 years earlier
and i'm working in the justice
department late one night and i'm
working on a program called stellar wind
which you may have heard of it's the
warrantless wiretapping program from the
bush administration
and to make another long story short
there are all sorts of problems in the
program and i was just starting to
figure it out and i was in the justice
department late one night
reading fourth amendment cases
and i'm reading a case called burger
versus new york which some of you may
remember and i'm reading along and there
are two citations
hofa versus united states
o'brien versus united states
i was kind of shocked i said can that
possibly be my stepfather
i looked up the case it turned out it
was a case involving chucky o'brien
when i was in high school chucky had
always said how corrupt the government
was they could break every rule in
secret they engage in illegal
surveillance all the time and they did
it to me and i had a famous supreme
court case he told me
i didn't believe him and i never knew
about this case
it turned out that was mostly true and
it turned out he was illegally
surveilled
in the early 1960s and it turned out
this case did vacate the conviction as
part of um
basically
um
cleaning up decades of surveillance
abuse by the government that finally
emerged in the public in the mid-60s
and he was the beneficiary of this
because the government actually was
illegally surveilling him and his lawyer
in
the office of a mob person that he was
close to
so this was shocking to me for many
reasons first of all i was in this very
stressful situation involving the
president of the united states and
warrantless surveillance of the war and
terrorism traumatic
and another traumatic period of my life
comes back and
it just came rushing back to me the
things that chucky said about the
justice department and how they could
cut corners and the like and there i was
knee-deep in a surveillance program
that had serious legal problems
and
some chucky basically in the large was
right about the 60s and it was still
true in the large when i was there in
the early 2000s
so this began a process for me that took
about a year the process in which i went
through a lot of soul searching about my
relationship with chucky
um and it involved a lot of things it
involved me
uh realizing that i had judged him very
harshly and that i had not paid
sufficient i had exaggerated my own
virtue
and uh un and uh under appreciated his
virtues
that he had never done anything wrong to
me uh and he'd only been a great father
to me
when i was in high school
um
he was ill
and
um
i appreciated his situation of being
charged with something bad that he
couldn't really fight because i was
actually when i left the government i
was
accused of doing things which i didn't
think were were fair and
but i couldn't really fight those
charges either so i sympathized with him
on that front
and finally i had two young children and
um
my mom had always told me how badly i
hurt chuckie when i broke with him
but i didn't really appreciate it until
i had my own children
and when i began to reflect on
that the vulnerability and the love i
had for my children and the pain that
would happen to me if i did to they did
to me what i'd done to chucky
all these reasons came together to lead
me to ask for his forgiveness in late
2004.
it happened in a very uh casual way i
was we were sitting watching seinfeld
and uh
in the television room he wasn't well he
was sitting in his chair and i turned to
him and i said
i was wrong to do what i did to you 20
years ago i hope you'll forgive me
and he looked at me and
he was surprised because we this is the
first this is the first trip that i'd
seen him really
with any amount of time we had a good
couple of days together it was like the
good old days
but he was shocked when i said this and
he looked at me
and his face was ashen and his eyes were
hollow and he started to tear up and he
said you don't have to apologize son i
understand why you did what you did
and that was it
that was the end of any discussion of
what had happened in the previous 20
years he forgave me
he let me back in his life we became
very close we spent a lot of time
talking of over the next seven years
excuse me
and over the course of these
conversations
i started to doubt whether he was the
person who picked up jimmy hoffa for a
whole bunch of reasons i didn't have any
evidence and i didn't know anything
about the case but just the way he
talked about it and the way he revered
hoffa
and so i said to him
one day about seven eight years ago
i said why don't i write a book about
this i said i'm sure whatever i find
whatever i discover about
what happened in the hoffa case that
it's got to give you a fair shake than
you've been given because every book
that had been written had had him
driving hover to his death that's the
conventional wisdom
and so i
he hesitated
he hesitated at first i thought he would
jump at this to have me write a book
about his life with hoffa and a book
that
tried to vindicate him from the charge
that he drove hapa to his death and let
me just say he was like this with hapa
hoffa was a father figure to him so he
was basically being charged with
patricide
and it was just terrible it and this
charge that was floated in the 70s and
his conventional wisdom everywhere
is it ruined his life for a whole bunch
of reasons it dishonored him it ruined
his life in the teamsters union
and it just basically destroyed him
and he tried to fight back and he could
never fight back he didn't have the
rhetorical or financial or legal tools
to even confront these charges
so i told him i would do my best to try
he finally came around and said okay
i said just one condition
i'll write this book i'll do my best
i'll try to clear you i try to figure
out what happened and i'll write the
best book i can but i do this on one
condition
you have to tell me the truth
he looked at me with his eyes and scans
this was a major challenge
because chucky
i learned when i read what something
called the hawfex
memory i didn't need to read the hopics
memorandum the hawfix memorandum was the
early fbi report about the case and it
referred to chucky as all of his friends
say he's a notorious pathological liar
i didn't need to i knew this he he
always
shaded the truth about everything
so that's one set of challenges that my
my main witness that i'm trying to clear
is is unreliable
another challenge was there's so
much misinformation
built up about the hoffa disappearance
over the years mostly based on the early
1970s theories
so many claims and counter claims that
sifting through that to try to get to
the truth
it was extremely difficult
spent seven years doing it talked to
every fbi agent who ever worked the case
who was alive became friends with many
of them
i looked at thousands of pages of
government documents many of which have
never been discussed in in public about
the case
and um
and chucky and i developed a rapport we
spent
cert probably thousands of hours
more than a thousand certainly uh
talking about the case
and
it was this amazing dance where i was
the
the the interrogator and he would
sometimes answer me straight sometimes
not answer usually try to deflect
but over time he told me quite a lot
not everything but quite a lot
to make a long story short i in the book
i do believe that uh i accomplished my
original goal i accomplished my original
goal of clearing him from the charge
that he was the person who drove hoffa
to his death
i think everyone has read the book i
hope you agree if you read it has has
agreed with that conclusion
there are lots of reasons i won't go
through them the circumstantial case
against him is full of polls there was
lots of evidence that the government
didn't talk about or didn't know about
early in the case that developed to
suggest he didn't or couldn't have done
it
the most salient piece of evidence for
me
was that the fbi starting in the 1990s
believed that chucky was not the person
who drove over to his death this is not
known in public
uh and they had all sorts of good
reasons for that and i talk about this
in the book and
why they came to the conclusion that
chucky was not involved
in part because they developed an
alternate theory of the case the case as
it's known in the public today is much
different from the case that the
government
understands today all of this is talked
about in the book so the book is in part
about my journey
kind of a journey of atonement to try to
clear chucky
along the way and i think i succeed in
that but along the way fortunately or
unfortunately it turned into something
much more than that it turned into
a narrative about the rise of labor in
the 20th century which was which hoffa
represented and the decline of labor
which he also represented
the rise of the mob in the 20th century
and the decline of the mob which was
closely connected to hoffa's
rise and fall
and the things and the steps that the
government took
to
both
diminish labor and to try to diminish
the mob and it's a fascinating story
uh it has really hasn't been adequately
told in my opinion i'd do my best to
tell it
along the way i also learned a lot about
law enforcement
and the fbi as i say i became very close
with some of the early fbi agents the
four original fbi agents on the hoffa
case who were in their early 30s
the man who originally accused chucky of
doing this um
uh we became friends we spent
12 sessions together hours and hours and
hours and hours and hours talking about
the case going over the evidence they've
never stopped obsessing about it no one
who's ever worked about this case has
ever stopped obsessing about it i don't
think dan has stopped obsessing about it
none of the fbi agents have stopped
assessing about it they still
talk about it try to think about it
they're still involved in trying to
solve the mystery
but i also learned about pretty
extraordinary law enforcement abuses um
and
the the government did not treat chucky
well chucky was a man who
was not an angel
he
he definitely not an angel
and there were good reasons as i say for
the government to suspect him
but it turns out that the public
narrative that the government leaked on
chucky didn't match up at all with
what the government knew inside they
were constantly exaggerating in the
press through leaks
the evidence they had against him to try
to get him to talk they were constantly
portraying him as the person who did it
to try to get him to talk to try to
pressuring him into talking
in the hopes either that he would be
feel pressured by that or he would feel
pressured by the mob they were
constantly telling him the mob is going
to come after him if he didn't mess up
after the government figured out that he
wasn't the person who did it the
government
they never corrected the record
there's a mechanism for leaking
allegations and putting it out there
and
for 45 44 years he's been accused in the
public eye of this thing there was a
mechanism for that there's no mechanism
for putting that genie back in the
bottle
and uh it's just not there's no
incentive in it for the government to do
that once it's out there there's every
incentive for them not to
and then most extraordinarily in 2013
the government approached chucky i
approached them they approached chucky
and they offered to actually send him an
exonerating letter to confirm that they
didn't believe he was a target or a
suspect in the case
all he had to do they said is to come in
for an interview
tell the truth
and he would get this letter
chucky was a very old man we went to
detroit
went to the interview in the us
attorney's office he spent four hours
with them it was actually a hilarious
interview he had everybody in stitches
he told the truth about everything and
they agreed that he told the truth about
everything
and they promised the letter
and two or three weeks later they said
the letter was coming
and then it was a month and then it was
two months and four months and six
months
and then letter never came
and the letter never came because the
political people at the top the u.s
attorney and the head of the fbi all the
people that worked the case for decades
the assistant u.s attorney the fbi
agents in charge of the case for decades
were convinced for a whole bunch of
reasons that i talked about in the book
that he didn't do it but they didn't
give them the letter they were nicked
so
and i tell the story of that and it's a
story poor chucky every turn i mean he's
had bad luck most of his life
the book also as i said in the
introduction it's also a history because
this intersected very much with hoba's
life in my life it's a history of the
american surveillance state
uh
i spent a lot of time going through
these extraordinary illegal
transcripts of recordings of illegal
bugs in the early 1960s and late 1950s
of the mob
and it's a story that's from a familiar
story it's a story of the fbi engaging
in illegal bugging
with what chucky referred to as backup
i.e the justice department wrote
memoranda in secret saying it's okay
familiar story and they were extremely
unconvincing opinions they were terrible
but this practice went on for decades
and it reached its height in the early
60s it finally leaked out there was
reform
i tell the story of that but most
extraordinarily
that story of that round of government
access and surveillance tied up in lots
of ways that i don't have time to tell
you with my experience in the government
with stellar wind in three or four
different ways there's a connection
between what hoffa went through and what
i what i was doing in the government 50
years later
finally just a couple more things about
the book the book has many themes um
uh i'll just talk about two more two
more of them and i'll stop one is
there are lots of historical ironies
that i talk about the book as i said is
about
the mob and and labor and their
relationship over the course of the 20th
century
and there are lots of interesting
historical ironies that took place bobby
kennedy who went after uh hoffa very
very aggressively crossing several lines
in my opinion and in the opinion of many
um
he thought that he was gonna
get rid of hoffa and save the american
labor movement and to save the teamsters
members from this horrible person at the
top of the union i can assure you that
the members of the teamsters union who
are doing great under hoffa trusted the
working class hoffa much more than the
the preppy millionaire who was chucky
said never did a real day's work in his
life
but the irony was that
in his super aggressive attacks on hoffa
he painted bobby painted with a hugely
broad brush i'm talking about the
mcclellan committee for those of you
know about it he painted with a broad
brush that stained all of labor and the
meme about labor corruption really got
going in the late 50s and 60s you can
see it
dropping in public approval of unions
over the time that kennedy was going
after hoffa so that's one
historical irony another historical
irony is kennedy was convinced bobby
kennedy was convinced if he can get rid
of hoffa decapitate hoffa from the top
of the teamsters union that will get rid
of the mob influence in the teamsters
union exactly the opposite happened
hoffa did dealings with the mob but he
also kept them at bay he was in charge
and especially with regard to the
pension fund when he went away his very
weak successor frank fitzsimmons
let the mob take over so actually
decapitating hoffa led to
much greater mob infiltration of the
teamsters union
than uh than it happened before
something that also kennedy did not
expect the third irony
is the mob had taken over the teamsters
hof was trying to get it back
and it was really the mob's decision to
knock off jimmy hoffa in 1975
that finally and i tell this story as
well finally led the government with
some tools congress had given it in the
late 60s and early 70s to get its act
together to have the resources to act
and and to discover when they they put
massive resources on the hoffa case and
in the course of that these amazing
memos in internal justice department
memos when they talk about
my god we've uncovered labor
racketeering and mob connections in
between the mob and the teamsters as if
uh the mcclellan committee never existed
it's much much worse than we realized
and this is the time starting with the
hoffa disappearance that led the
government to get together the resources
and the tools to really aggressively go
after labor racketeering and fairly
successfully wouldn't say wipe it out
but diminish it significantly and so the
mob miscalculated as i quote one of the
fbi agents in the case if jimmy hoffa
were still on the street
there would be a lot more mobsters still
on the street
finally and briefly i'll just say that
the book is about
and this is the hardest topic to
summarize so i'll just close here it's
about fathers and sons
and
treachery between fathers and sons sons
and fathers loyalty and forgiveness
jimmy hoffa lost his father when he was
seven years old his father died
chucky lost his father when he was seven
years old his dad took off him
because he had trouble with the mob in
kansas city
my father left me when i was seven years
old we were all little boys in search of
stability hoffa never had a real father
figure he was he did it on his own
chucky's father figures were jimmy hoffa
and anthony jacqueline a senior mob
leader in detroit
who themselves were very close
and chucky lived and revered both men
but jackalone was the person
that was behind at least involved in
hoffa's disappearance and chucky was
caught in that vice
and to make matters worse of course he
was seen as treacherous because he was
seen as the person who
killed his father essentially or had his
father killed which um
and then finally
about my relationship with chuckie and
the book is basically about
in addition to everything else about my
changing views about chucky over the
different stages of my life and how he
looked when i was 20 because of how i
looked when i was 20 and my perspective
then and how it looked differently after
i've been through the incredible fire of
my job in the justice department
and then how it looked even more
different after 10 or 12 years more
talking to him as he got very old and
near death
and i'm getting pretty old too and the
book's a reflection on that and some of
the complications in our relationship
but really in the end about how all of
this brought us much much closer than
we'd ever been before
so that's what the book's about it's
about lots of things and i'm very happy
to take your questions
[Applause]
i really enjoyed your book thank you
it was a good read my question is you
talked a lot about how
chucky had i've got the name of it but
he had had this idea of not talking
about everything
merita amerita yeah do you think if he
would have told everything he knew that
he would have gotten that letter i think
it was from barbara mccaid
equator no oh so just to be clear
he answered every single question
that the government asked him they were
asking him questions about his
involvement in the disappearance
they wanted to clear him because they
hoped if they cleared him this was their
theory to me and to him that he would
cooperate in telling them what he knew
about the disappearance the other things
he knew yeah so he told them he answered
all of their questions completely fully
and he he he satisfied every
condition that they every question that
he asked
um i don't i mean he told me a lot of
things later they didn't ask him these
questions they didn't ask him what he
knew about all these other collateral
things because there's no way he's going
to answer that until he gets off the
legal jeopardy hook which was on
um
a big part of the book i didn't mention
this chucky
was half sicilian half irish
but he was raised with what he calls
sicilian values he came his mother came
from kansas city crime family
and his mother schooled him on omerta
the code of silence uncle tony giacoloni
uh schooled him on the code of silence
and he this was the most important
principle in his life and it kept
beating up against his desire to help me
write this truthful book that he knew i
needed to write
and a lot of the book is about our
struggle to work through
his commitment to emerita and my
commitment to figuring out everything he
knew and it was a struggle right to the
very end as i talk about in the book
first thank you for being here and
putting the stuff about fathers and sons
in the book which didn't have to be in
there you could have told the story
without it is really
emotionally a great thing thank you i
have one quick question and one longer
question quick question you live in
arkansas when your mom met chuckie
o'brien and how did that happen no and
then the second part is uh
i paint houses i think the name of the
book is
um where the
the guy who's he didn't write it but he
told it to a reporter
um says that basically he was the one
who killed hoffa yep
and what do you think you think he's
being true he's dead now but do you
think that was truthful or no so i'll
answer those two questions but i want to
comment on the first thing you said yeah
so the book is about fathers and sons
and it's really about
um
about a lot of things about fathers and
sons but it's also about forgiveness
and the power of forgiveness
and i didn't realize
what an important theme this was i just
wrote the book for what i i thought was
important about my relationship with
chuckie and what i learned about that
but the main comment made feedback i've
gotten from
[Music]
dozens now of men all men was thank you
for writing this book because it made me
realize
issues i have in my family with my
parents and the importance of
forgiveness in those relationships and
so i'm just that's the most surprising
reaction to the book
is that people appreciated that and were
helped by it
on your questions about west memphis so
i my
chucky was living in detroit and my mom
was actually living in florida but with
with she has three boys i was the oldest
but my grandmother lived in west memphis
that's where i was raised so we happened
to be there that summer she had met
chuckie through chucky's mother who was
a very consequential woman amazing woman
in in labor and mob circles
and uh so
basically chucky was in detroit brenda
was in west memphis my mom they got
married and then they moved to florida
as for the book there's a movie coming
out by martin scorsese about hoffa
called the irishman which is based on a
book called i heard you paint houses
and the book is based on a confession of
frank sheeran uh who was a teamsters
official and
uh a hit man or at least a
a a criminal a serious criminal
and sheeran
gave a confession that turned into the
basis of this book which has now been
made into a motion picture
and the confession is to to use a
technical term rubbish
i've written a long essay in the new
york review of books and uh there's more
to say about it
but there's absolutely zero evidence to
support it no evidence at all to support
the confession and lots of reasons to
think it's false
every person i talked to in the fbi gave
me lots of good reasons why there's no
way sharon did it but
it's a very cleverly written book and
now it's the basis for a motion picture
so and most importantly for me
so she the book is basically based on
the early 1970s theory the case that
everyone knows about and writes on
and he has chucky drive i mean i haven't
read the seen the movie yet but in the
book he has chucky picking up hoffa
because that's what the commercial
wisdom was he just inserts himself into
that
so i fear i'm sure the movie i suspect
that the movie has chucky driving him to
his death and uh
i i suspect that the scorsese movie is
going to be more influential than my
account of what the fbi now thinks and
the reasons for it which is unfortunate
thank you so much um i can't help but
wonder how this
grenade landing in the middle of your
family of the hoffa events
affected the other members like your
brothers and your mother
thank you
so my brothers and i were very young and
i was 12 my brothers were seven and um
i was 12 my brothers were eight and five
they were very young and it was
traumatic for all of us and we all dealt
with it in different ways but the person
who was most devastated by it was my mom
she had mental health problems
before this event
and
they got significantly worse as a result
of
the investigation the publicity the
charges the constant reporters
the stress being called before a grant
the grand jury which she actually didn't
have to attend because of her mental
health problems
had a devastating effect on her
as for me this is seems strange and
implausible it was a wild time
but the main thing i remember about
those five years this seems impossible
was happiness
because of my relationship with chucky
we were extremely close
and
i had a pretty good experience in high
school he went to all my sports events
we did everything together
i don't remember it i'm sure i've
suppressed a lot i don't remember it as
a terrible time in my life i remember it
as
an improvement in my life and as a
stable and happy time in my life it was
not good for my mom though it was
terrible for her
thank you
hi yeah and thank you for your
interesting story thank you
it's a small point i guess but i was
wondering how is it that chucky was able
to get
information about the information that
turned out to be truthful about
the government surveillance of
of himself and of others
this was something you were skeptical of
at one point in your life and then came
to realize was true right but you had
inside information to learn that it was
true he didn't so no no that's that's
not accurate i'm sorry if i misled you
so
there was
starting the late 50s
when hoover jagger hoover the fbi
director finally became advan convinced
for a whole bunch of reasons in the late
50s that he had to take
organized crime
seriously
his first line of attack was to use
mostly bugs sometimes
wire surveillance to gather intelligence
on mob figures and this started in the
late 50s and it went through 1965 or so
it was not known at the time it was
secret but it all came out in the 60s
and indeed the reason chucky knew about
it is because
the government disclosed when the
government revealed all this illegal
activity the supreme court
ordered them basically to say well what
are you going to do they had they had to
confess errors to the court thurgood
marshall was the solicitor general
they confessed error to the court they
said what they thought the legal basis
was they said they'd stop doing these
things
they presented a plan to the court in
which they pledged to the court that
they would reveal every case in which
there was even close to illegal
surveillance
and confess error about that
chucky's case was one of those he got
lucky because of this
of these leaks about this in the 60s so
he learned about it in the 60s and that
was the basis
for his um
for his conviction being vacated more
generally i mean one of the many things
i learned in writing this book was
you know we live in an era of
surveillance paranoia and there's every
reason to be paranoid not just because
of what the government's doing but
mostly just because everybody's watching
all the time there are sensors on
everything
there was
dramatic paranoia in the early 60s there
was story after story after story
about the newfangled recording devices
that were around every corner and that
were watching us and storing the data it
sounds very much like what we talk about
today and hoffa had lots of reasons to
think that he was being surveilled the
government was very aggressively
following him he believed he was being
illegally wiretapped he was never able
to prove it
but the short answer to your question is
the illegal surveillance came out in the
60s chucky learned about it then he
didn't learn about the extent of it the
reason i know about the extent of it is
because this is a long story and i'll
make short
all of these
transcripts from all of these almost a
lot of these illegal recordings in the
early 60s are available in public now
as part of believe it or not
the 1980s investigation into the
assassination of john f kennedy
and they collected all sorts of evidence
about the government and the mob and the
course of doing that these documents
ended up being in the public record
that's how i got access to all of these
documents but chucky learned about it in
the 60s
thank you
i i can still remember watching uh
senator mcclellan and bobby kennedy as
an extremely tiny person uh do you have
any sense
or general comment you'd like to say
about whether the teamsters are a force
for good or ill in the history of the
country today or in the history of the
country
so even a little bit maybe i'll talk i
can talk more about the 50s and 60s
and 40s
and 70s than i can about today
that's the period i studied for the book
and talked about
and it's it's a story of tragedy i think
um
so it's hard to exaggerate how powerful
the teamsters union was in the 50s and
60s and they were powerful because hoffa
basically expanded the bargaining unit
to the national level
and that meant that he could by
closing down
transportation routes and failing to
deliver or failing deliveries to happen
at crucial strategic points he could put
economic leverage on anyone
and this is before
and the government tried to clamp down
on this through labor laws but basically
the teamsters had extraordinary power
hoffa was extremely successful
in growing the power of the teamsters
extremely successful at bringing many
hundreds of thousands of workers many
hundreds of thousands out of poverty and
into the middle class he was just very
successful at bringing home the bacon
for his union and considered narrowly
he was good for labor in terms of being
good for the teamsters at least in that
short period of time
ultimately however and there was this
promise i mean i don't think it was ever
a serious promise but
hoffa was on the outs with all the rest
of labor for a whole bunch of reasons in
part because of his commitments he
thought that they were captured by
various interests but in part because he
was corrupt
and
you know in a counterfactual world hoffa
might have led the
if
didn't have this conventional corruption
in a counterfactual world he could have
led labor in a very different direction
ultimately he ended up doing great
damage to the labor movement even though
he because basically his performance at
the mcclellan committee
was
one of it's basically indifference to
the corruption and criminality around
him
and um his indifference to those things
really just had had an effect far beyond
the teamsters in terms of tarring the
whole labor movement so
it's hard to make very sweeping
generalities but i think on the whole
hoffa though
a brilliant and very effective labor
leader on the whole i think his impact
has to be seen as negative on balance
and there was a real contrast between he
and dave back at the time well dave beck
was his predecessor and he was um
you know they both
beck
beck was his pr the predecessor to hoffa
in the team cheers union and he beck had
similar tactics he wasn't his gr he
wasn't he used these similar um
similar bargaining techniques that hoffa
perfected
he wasn't the charismatic leader hoffa
was and he had different kinds of
corruption hoffa's corruption i'll just
say hoffa was always making side deals
and always amassing cash
according to chucky tens of millions of
dollars there was just cash everywhere
and i believe it for it was confirmed by
a whole lot of things i found in my
research
but hafa wasn't spending it on himself
and he didn't have a fancy life
he was spending it
to enhance his power to buy people off
to buy politicians off to buy judges off
to buy off anyone who would help him and
he identified his power with teamsters
power and that was more or less true
not completely back
was was more more conventionally corrupt
in terms of lining his pockets for his
his benefit
yes
hi thank you um
i haven't read all of your book just a
portion of it and i've scanned some of
it but you have said that while chuckie
didn't get the letter to exonerate him
um you said the fbi did know who did it
and who do they say so i i tell you
so um
over the course of
many spending a lot of time with people
with government officials in detroit
uh i kind of triangulated and figured
out
what their current theory is
and their current theory of the case for
which which is based on
surveillance evidence conversations that
they overheard and informant evidence
is that the um
they think they know who did it they
think that vito giacalone who was the
son through the brother of anthony
giaciloni who was michael tony
uh
was the person who actually picked off
up and they have reasons to think that
and they think that i'm not going to
mention the name for reasons i'll
explain in a second they think they know
the person was who actually killed hoffa
they caught him on tape bragging about
it in a way that was corroborated with
some other pieces of information that
they had
this corroboration was the basis for the
2013 dig the last of a dozen dicks to
look for hoffa uh so they think they
know the two two people that and this
person who was a very low level member
of the detroit crime family quickly rose
in prominence to the detroit ranks
i didn't mention his name in the book
because
for a couple of reasons and i'm not sure
where i should have drawn the line i
didn't mention his name in the book
because
i don't know what the fbi's evidence is
the fbi has had many theories over the
years and they seem very confident about
this theory i mentioned veto because
he's been conventionally mentioned as a
as
a
suspect
my publisher wanted me to mention the
other name but i didn't because
i found it very frustrating that chucky
was just mentioned as a suspect based on
what the fbi thought
and um that turned out not to be true
and this gentleman is dead he died
but i just thought that i shouldn't
do what i didn't appreciate others doing
to chucky so i didn't mention his name
in the book but they do think they know
i believe
based on conversations with people in
detroit and the government
that they are
going to release this information at
some point in the near future
thank you thank you
i love the book and i'm a victim of
starting with dan maldea and yours and
steve brill and everybody else
uh at the end of the book i love the
book and i think everybody should read
it uh thank you uh
your stepfather does tip his hand a bit
and indicate that tony provenzano was
likely involved in it right is it
appropriate to ask you how you think it
connects up to the new jersey uh
mob
well so um
chucky tried hard not to tell me things
he wasn't supposed to tell me but he did
tell me some things that he wasn't
supposed to tell me
and one of the things he told me was
that tony probanzano who was a teamsters
official in new jersey teamsters and a
member of the genovese family i think
was as has been widely suspected since
1975 involved in the
uh in the organization of the plot and
he didn't give any details but he told
me this in an extremely credible way
that it was corroborated by a few things
and again it's not surprising that tony
pro uncle tony when i was growing up
that it's not surprising that uncle tony
was involved it but chucky's
corroboration i think is an important
point
um it seems pretty clear to me based on
what i learned from chucky what i've
learned from others
that the java hit was approved by the
commission the new york commission in
new york this was a
a decision that affected the whole
nation everybody
uh because hoffa was threatening to take
everyone down and there were going to be
consequences for everyone so it was the
decision made there
tony pro for a variety of reasons is on
the outs with hoffa and i think he was
the basically the intermediary between
the commission
and this is my speculation chucky didn't
tell me this but it's informed
speculation
and detroit especially anthony giacoloni
uh there's a lot of metadata information
which hasn't been fully explored in
public
showing communications between
jacqueline and provenzano which look
very much like
because of the the intensity and the
dates
and some of the other calls they made
looks very much like uh pro was working
with giacoloni
so that's that's the basic contours of
the conspiracy at the 40 000 foot level
does that answer your question
yeah
any other questions
um
professor goldsmith thank you for coming
and thank you for this wonderful book
and to follow on the last question i
have just one question remaining after
reading your book carefully
whatever happened to tony provenzano's
pool table
[Laughter]
that's a great question so
tony province on his pool table
uncle tony tony bravenzano was as chucky
said in the book the most uncontrollably
violent man i met in my life
uh and he had some other descriptions as
well
and
provenzano was um
[Music]
but that's not the tony pro i knew the
tony pro i knew when i was growing up
was this kind gentleman who was always
in a bathing suit in his hollanddale
home where we would often go to hang out
at the pool and have barbecues
and play on his gorgeous pool table he
had this gorgeous wooden pool table
and i was 13 or 14 then i was really
into pool and i loved that pool table
and i asked him where he got it and
where i could get one
and one day tony uncle tony called up
chucky and said come over here and get
this goddamn pool table and give it to
your children
which chucky did and we had this
beautiful tony pro pool table in our
garage in jacaranda in plantation
which i adore throughout my high school
years
and i don't know what happened to the
pool table i have to say if i had
understood the significance of the pool
table when i was 17 i would give
anything to have that pool table now but
i don't know what happened to it
i think about tony pro every time i play
pool
anybody else
let me echo everyone else's comments
absolutely amazing book um the question
i had uh uh kind of goes to the the
conversation you had with uh chucky i
think it was applebee's or one of those
kind of votes season's 52 seasons 52 um
where he you know reveals a lot more
than he's supposed to uh but it sounded
unlike most other conversations you had
with him he tried to retract a lot of
that yeah and so toward the end of the
book you talk a little bit about sort of
your internal struggle about how much of
that to publish yes um and i guess we'll
we'll never know exactly how much of
that you did publish because we don't
know what you didn't publish uh but um i
guess the question is you know kind of
talk through you know that because it
felt in the book a little bit uh
inconclusive where you sort of laid out
the case for both sides but then never
really resolved it one way or another
kind of like a lawyer yeah exactly which
i which i am so let me accept let me
explain what was just asked so everyone
can understand
so
[Music]
i learned a lot from chuckie over our
many many many hundreds of hours of
conversation and
even when
and he as i say he was always torn he
always had his mother's
visage in his
in the back of his head every time he
got close to telling me something he
said my mom's looking at me i can't say
that
and but he wanted to tell me things and
but he kept holding back and i wasn't i
really wasn't
i didn't push him because i actually
came to respect his i mean it seems
bizarre but i came to admire
this important principle for him because
it was basically all he had left at the
end of his life and he'd lost everything
else
but he still told me a lot even while
not sort of confessing everything
and then one day my mom had a heart
attack
and i came down to see her in boca raton
and chucky was there in the hospital and
he was in much worse shape than my mom
my mom was going to do okay but chuckie
was distraught about her
so my mom said take him to lunch at
seasons 52 and the food will calm him
down
this is a point in my conversations with
chucky when i had basically decided i
wasn't going to press him anymore he
told me what he was going to tell me and
i was going to write the book
we sit down at seasons 52 and i just
reflexively hit the voice the recorder
on my iphone because in all of our
conversations i just always hit the
recorder i had no expectation of having
any conversation
and i didn't even i just did it without
even thinking
and so we were talking along and
we weren't even talking we were talking
about my childhood and the good old days
when i was jack o'brien and the fun
things we did and then somehow the um
our trip to detroit the previous year
before this
interview with the government came up
and i just said without even
just just to be talking i said you know
those guys think
that tony pro
was involved and i know you don't think
that but they think they're pretty clear
that he and
and anthony jacqueline were involved
and chucky said
tony pro had a lot to do with it
and i was
stunned
i was stunned because he never
ever had talked about
he did it in a way that was very
credible and he had never
talked about tony pro's involvement in
the disappearance and he'd always given
me these stories which i didn't believe
about how he wasn't involved
and he looked down in his soup and he
proceeded for about 40 minutes to tell
me a whole bunch of things
and i learned a lot in that conversation
uh and a lot of what's new in the book
about the hoffler disappearance i
learned in that conversation and it was
when i realized a lot of things it was
in that conversation that i realized
that chucky and i didn't explain this
but the moment hoffa disappeared chucky
was in this vice
he was not involved but he knew a lot
about the backdrop he knew a lot about
the teamsters relationships with the mob
he knew all the players involved he
immediately knew what happened and why
and so when all this pressure from the
government was coming down on him the
government the mob was worried that
chucky was going to break and flip so he
had to be very careful about what he
said he had to get permission for every
time he talked to the government
i came to understand the incredible
pressures he was under but he also told
me a lot about the background not to
what happened that afternoon i don't
believe he knows what happened that
afternoon i don't believe they told him
he told me they didn't tell him and he
said he's glad he they didn't tell him
and he said he doesn't know want to know
what happened
but he told me a lot of things that he
and one of the many reasons that i
i found it credible that day and i came
to find it credible because as he
immediately regretted telling me what he
told me i didn't even he told me this
because he was distraught
and he was i don't know why he told me
he was distraught about my mom
and he was distraught and he was
exhausted and he just
downloaded
and i at that point this was a very
important point in the writing of the
book at that point i had a huge dilemma
from and the dilemma was
wow i just learned a lot of things that
go to the truth of a lot of things about
the hoffa disappearance
that is not known and it's credible and
i can't write this book if i can include
this information that's just crystal
clear to me
um on the other hand but then chucky a
couple of weeks later had a basically a
meltdown and said you can't put that
stuff in the book
and it wasn't because he feared for his
life it became clear it because
he would violate his honor he told me
something he wasn't supposed to and he
made this very clear to me
and i struggled and struggled with what
to do and my plan was
because i basically said to my publisher
i can either not write the book
i can't write the book without this
information or i can wait until chucky
passes away
and that was my plan i was going to
because
and yet i wanted to
exonerate him or show the world that he
didn't do this terrible thing but i
didn't want to stay in his honor in the
process
so but my my the way i had done it was i
wasn't going to publish the book until
he passed away well because of the
scorsese movie chucky
was very anxious for me to publish the
book because he wanted the world to know
that he didn't in fact drive java to his
death despite this movie and he was
putting a lot of pressure on me to
publish it
and so i decided time was running short
i said okay i'm going to let him decide
and i showed him the manuscript which
included
these things he told me not every single
detail but much of what he told me which
i found to be material
and i was going to let him decide let
him make the trade off about what he
valued most
i go down to boca raton florida i gave
him the manuscript on a monday
i say i needed it back by friday and my
publisher has to know that day whether
we're going forward
over the course of that tense week i was
sure he was going to say you can't
publish this
i saw him looking at the manuscript he
was wincing a few times
he asked me to take a few things out
completely non-material things meant
just the stupidest little things please
take that out out of respect for barbara
hoffa or whatever
but
the meat of the things he told me that
he might regret was at the end of the
book and i saw him flipping through to
the end of course and seeing what
happened friday comes around and i say i
have to know you want me to publish the
book or not
your call
and he handed me the manuscript with a
terribly sad face
and he said i read every word
you wrote a great book congratulations
son
and i thought what the hell does that
mean
because i don't think he read the book i
don't think he read to the end
and i don't know why
um i don't know if it was because it was
too painful i don't know if it's because
he didn't want the responsibility for it
i don't know if he decided to suck up
his honor so that i could publish this
book which i thought was important or i
don't know if he decided clearing my
name is more important than this
but he gave me the thumbs up
and um
i reflect to the end of the book in a
way that i can't really reproduce here
but i reflect at the end of the book
about
was i thinking about chucky was i
thinking about me
what was the right call did i do the
right thing
and it was a very very very tough
decision
i can report now that he is not well
he's near the end of his life i fear
but he is very pleased with the book he
um
he's struggled with it in various ways i
was a very candid book and i'm talk
about my warts and his and lots of other
people's as i say i tried to write an
honest book
but um the week it was published he
he had basically not talked to me about
it it was very concerning to me because
i wrote the book for him and i feared if
he hated it then i've failed
and um basically
he called me up a couple of days after
the book was published i had given him a
copy of the book a couple of weeks
earlier
and he was in tears and which he doesn't
often do
and he basically said i've read the book
three times i really read it this time
you wrote an amazing book i don't know
how you did it i don't know how you
figured all that stuff out you got it
exactly right
i'm terribly sorry i was such a pain in
the ass
and that for me made it worth writing
the book because i really do think that
i cleared his name from this it was a
very difficult call about what to put in
i still don't know if i made the right
call but that judgment by him for me
made it all okay
thank you very very much
thank you all very much for coming
and we will have a signing up here at
the table and there are books available
in the back and if i could remind you to
fold up your chairs that'd be fantastic
this is marty
book tv recently visited capitol hill
and asked republican